if you are going to use sql server at
any sort of scale you're going to have
to think about performance
in this course you will learn the
essentials of sql server performance
you will see how to diagnose what is
happening with a slow running sql
statement and what strategies are
available to make these statements run
faster or john aurora teaches this
course
to follow along with the course you
should have some development experience
and some experience with sql server this
course is divided into the six modules
you see on the screen now
you're going to learn everything from
analyzing sql statements for performance
to applying common best practices to
ensure the best possible performance i
encourage you to leave a comment with
the most interesting thing you learn for
the benefit of other campers who are
watching this course
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 1 course
introduction
it is very annoying for every developer
to get the result very slow from the
queries that we are executed on the
database
and the slow result leads to the slow
application performance which leads to
unsatisfied customers
in this course i am going to show you
what you need to know as a developer
about sql server to make sure that your
data access code is performing well
as a developer i am assuming that you
are already comfortable in analyzing and
debugging code in languages like c sharp
and java
but you may be uncomfortable with your
level of knowledge of sql server
and how things works in the database
in this course i will help you feel more
comfortable when you are working with
sql server
especially for the times that you are
diagnosting and solving the performance
issue
and this is the most important part
because in almost all system that we
build our database is a critical
component of the whole system
so it is very important to understand
that a database like sql server works so
that we can make sure that we are
getting the most out of it
in this course we are going to focus on
the performance aspect that we as a
developer have control over
that is making sql statement run as
efficiently as possible
and making sure that our application
avoids the use of some well-known data
access anti-patterns that are common
cause for the performance problem
this will give you the number of
benefits for the application that we
build
the first benefit is efficient sql
statements means that our statements
will run faster
making our application more responsive
to our valuable users
second benefit is efficient data access
means that our application will be more
scalable
so we will be able to serve more number
of users and transactions on the same
hardware
and finally we know that many
applications are deployed on the cloud
either as sql server deployed on a
virtual machine hosted in the cloud
or by using a platform as a service
solutions like sql azure
when you are hosting in the cloud you
have to pay for the resources that you
use
so in that case if you have an
inefficient sql
it doesn't just make your application
slow
but it actually cost more to run since
you are using more resources
so you can see there are pretty much
reasons why we want to understand how we
can access our data in sql server as
efficient as possible
now there are some arguments that sql
server performance is solely the domain
of the database administrators
but i believe it is important equally
for application developers to have a
strong grip of sql server performance
concepts
so let's discuss it in the next video
why you as a application developer
should learn about sql server
performance
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 2 why developers
should understand sql server performance
there are many reasons why you as a
developer should understand sql server
performance
one of the biggest reason is that
generally the responsibility of the
overall performance of the app is on the
shoulders of the application development
team
and we all know that how much
application performance is important for
the user experience in today's time
if our application is slow and
unresponsive or can't scale to meet the
number of users it need to be then the
user is not satisfied with the app and
looks for the alternative
the second reason is as an application
developer we have the view or scope for
the whole system along with the
knowledge of the application code we
also have an idea of the use cases for
the application
and the data being used stored accessed
by the application
most important we have a view of how all
the pieces of the applications fit
together into different feature of our
application
and how these features are used by our
users
at the time of tuning sql statements or
creating indexes in our database it is
always good if we understand the larger
context of our application such as what
the application is trying to do
and how it is trying to do
so our knowledge of how the application
works is greatly benefited in this case
finally there will be no doubt at the
times when you need to work closely with
the dba team at your company
this might be to search an issue from an
application or do some database design
work
or any other reason
by better knowing how sql server works
you will be able to engage or help your
dbas more efficiently
you will be able to work more
effectively analyzing problems and you
will better understand what tools are
available and how they can help solve
these problems
in the next video we are going to see
what tools you required to follow along
with me
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 3 tools you need
in this course you will see me working
in the local copy of sql server 2019
developer edition
however the lessons and techniques in
this course will also be applicable in
sql server 2008 2012
2014 2016 and also in 2017.
if there is difference in how you
perform something i will point that also
if you are using azure sql as your
database then there are no worries
the tools and techniques you are going
to see will also be applicable in that
case also
if there is difference in how you
perform something i will point out that
also
there is a misconception among many
peoples that to really understand sql
server performance you need fancy
expensive tools
but it is not always true
in fact all the tools that we are going
to use in this course have already been
installed on your workstation
as they are a part of the sql server
client installation
if you have already installed sql server
management studio
you are ready for this course
the features that i am going to show you
in this course are already present in
management studio and you might be
unaware of those features
i will also show you how we can query
performance data out of sql server
dynamic management views from management
studio
and how we can use management studio to
set up event traces
so by having basic sql server client
tool installed and knowing how to use
them you are done to accomplish almost
all the performance tuning that you need
to do
you have to download sql server
developer edition so that you can
install the sample database and follow
along
i suggest to download from the link
shown on screen
and i will provide this link in the
description box for your convenience
press download
and run the setup file
and follow the instructions
after installing sql server
you have to download and install sql
server management studio which is also
called ssms
you can download it from the link shown
on the screen
or i will provide the link in the
description box for your convenience
on this link click download sql server
management studio
and run the setup file and follow the
instruction
now speaking of demos
i have a sample database for this course
that based on a fictional university
that all of the demos are based
so in the next video i will show you how
you can download a copy of the database
and get that imported in your instance
of sql server
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 4
restore the sample database
we are going to use the sample database
throughout this course and this database
contains enough data so that we can do
some performance tuning on sql
statements and get a feel of how things
are going on in the database
so first you have to download the simple
data
and you can download it from the link
shown on the screen
and i will provide this link in the
description box also for your
convenience
download the appropriate file for the
version of sql server that you have
installed
this is going to download a sql server
backup file
called students.b
we will take this file and restore this
in sql server to create a sample
database
to do this you have to go into sql
server management studio
and then in the database folder we just
going to rightly
and we select restore database
that's going to bring up the dialog box
here
and we want to choose the second radio
button which is device
and then we will click on these three
dots here to find our file
then we will click add and this will
bring up the file explorer here
and i have my file out here in the d
drive under the folder sql backups
select the dot bak file
i will say ok
everything looks good here so i will say
ok again
and then this is going to go ahead and
start the restore process
so now you can see that i have this
database
and i can access this
i have my tables in here
i can use this just like any other
database on my system
so now that we have the sample database
installed
in the next video
i will cover some basic sql server
concepts you need to understand
around tables and indexes before we dive
into analyzing sql statements in the
next module
so we will go ahead and do that next
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 5 table concepts
i would like to go through a couple of
sql server concepts that will come up
over and over again throughout the
course to make sure that you are
familiar with them
we have all worked with tables of sql
server
but many of us may not have given much
thought to how sql server actually
stores the data inside the table
typically
table data in sql server is stored in
the form of cluster index structure
this means the data in the table will be
stored in a tree like structure
like you can see on the screen
at the bottom of this tree
we have the leaf nodes of the tree
and this is where the actual data rows
for the table are stored
each of these leaf nodes is what is
known as a page in sql server
and the page is 8 kb in size
depending on the size of the rows a
table contains
each page will generally store somewhere
between 50 to a few hundred rows of data
inside of it
what is important to know is that the
data in these bottom nodes of the tree
is actually stored in sorted order
and that sorted order is determined what
is called the cluster key of the table
by default the primary key of the table
will be cluster key
by having the data in sorted order in
this bottom nodes sql server can
maintain the tree structure like you see
over the top of the data the nodes at
the top of the page allow sql server to
quickly traverse the tree and find the
data it's looking for
as we will see in example on the slide
in the sample database i have a table
named students
and the primary key of the student table
is the student id column
so student id would be our cluster key
in this case what that means is that
down here in my leaf nodes where the
data is stored my student data would be
in sorted order by the student id
so in this example the first leave node
is going to be storing the data rows for
students 1 to 100 the second node will
be storing the rows for students 101 to
200 and so on
in this top two levels of the tree we
have a series of pointers that will help
direct us to the data
so let's say now that we want to find
the row for student number 327
we start up here at the root node and it
will tell us that we need to go to the
intermediate node that is leaf node that
is in the second from the left
and it is in the leaf node where we will
find the data that we are looking for
so you see you are able to traverse this
tree in just three operations
even for tables that have hundreds of
thousands or even millions of rows in
them
by using a tree structure like this sql
server is able to find the data it is
looking for in a just few operations
this tree structure that sql server uses
for storing data is very efficient as
long as we are looking up data by how
the data is stored in the table
in this case by the primary key which is
a student id column
however we often need to be able to look
up the data by some other criteria say
in this example we want to search for a
student by their first name or last name
and this creates a problem our data down
here in the leaf nodes is sorted by
student id
but there is no correlation between a
student's id number and their name
students names will effectively have a
random distribution throughout all the
data pages
at the bottom of the table
so we have no idea where a particular
name may be
so what sql server will do in this case
is perform a scan of the structure
meaning it will read each and every one
of these data pages here at the bottom
of the cluster index structure looking
for the data that matches your criteria
for a table of any significant size
though you will have hundreds or even
thousands of these data pages
in the bottom of the tree
most likely many of this would need to
be read of the disk so there is a
significant i o cost and then sql server
will have to use lot of cpu in order to
read through each and every row
what we can do though is we can create
an index on our table
though to help sql server finding that
data more efficiently
so let's discuss the index in the next
video
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 6 index concepts
a database index help us quickly find
data in a table when we are searching
for data by some other criteria other
than the cluster key that our table is
organized by
for the example that we have just talked
about searching for students by name
we would want to create an index on the
students table over the last name and
the first name column
as you see an index uses a tree
structure just like our table
but
in this case the entries in the index
are sorted by the index key
which is in this case is the combination
of the last name and the first name
column
and the index does not contain the
actual data rows
instead in the bottom nodes of the index
that are represented
and marked with the rp
the index will contain row pointers back
to the table which indicates where the
corresponding data in the table is
located
if we look in the detail onto one of the
bottom nodes in the index it would look
something like this
we see here that we have the key of the
index the last name and the first name
of the students
and those are in sorted order
and then we have the student id value
for that student
so for example
if we have a sql statement with the
where clause that you see on your screen
where we are searching for this student
by name sql server will first traverse
the tree structure of the index to find
the student id number
and then it will traverse the tree
structure of the table to locate the
data for the student
so there are actually two operations
that must occur
but each of this operation is very
efficient
and is usually turn out to be much
faster to do these two operations
traversing the tree structure
then to scan through all the rows of a
table
we also can and often do have multiple
indexes on a table in order to cover the
different ways our application
might search for data in that table
so if we think about the students table
we might want to find a student by the
name as we just talk about or perhaps by
their email addresses
so in this case we would create two
separate indexes on the students table
each index being targeted in a way that
our application searches for the data in
the table
what all of this means is that if your
sql statement is using some criteria to
locate data other than the primary key
we are going to want that statement to
use an index
this way we can take the advantage of
the tree structure of the index to
quickly find the pointer to the data
that we need and this is much more
efficient and therefore much faster than
having to scan through all the rows in
the table from the next video we will
start our next module which is module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
in that we will see what our sql
statements are doing in the sql server
you are watching the video of module 1
getting started part 7 summary of this
module
in this introductory module we talked
about why it is important for you as a
application developer to understand sql
server performance
almost every application written is
going to use a database backend
in some way
and the database is almost always an
important component of overall
application performance
since we as application developers
understand what our application is
trying to do
when it runs a statement against sql
server
we can be very effective at database
performance tuning once we know what to
look for
because we understand the larger context
that all of our sql is running on
we also covered the tools that you need
to analyze sql server performance
then we discuss how to get the sample
database downloaded and installed so you
can follow along throughout the course
and finally
we covered some basic concepts around
how sql server stores data in tables and
how indexes works
so that we have a solid understanding of
these fundamentals for the future
modules in this course
here
we have successfully finished module 1
getting started
in the next module we are going to start
looking at how to analyze the
performance of individual sql statements
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
part 1 module introduction
so you have a sql statement that is
running slow
or
maybe you just have a statement that you
aren't sure is optimized correctly
and you need to know what to do next
that is what this module is all about
understanding how to analyze any sql
statement to tell what they are doing
and how they are doing to perform in a
very quantitative way
the first step in this process is to
have sql statement give us an execution
plan
which is the detail steps of how sql
server will run our statement when we
submitted it to the database
after that we will understand how to
read the execution plan that sql server
gives back to us
and how we make sense of what sql server
is telling us from a performance point
of view
we will also see how sql server
calculates a cost value for each
statement
and in fact for each operation within a
statement
and by looking at these cost values we
will tell what statements and operations
are relatively more expensive than
others
we also see how sql server can give us
execution statistics on our statements
and this means the amount of cpu and io
that the statement is consuming
what all of this allows us to do is to
understand in a very quantitative way
how expensive
a sql statement is
and then when we started tuning that
statement we have some very good metrics
in place to judge just how much we have
improved
the performance of this statement
we are also going to see little bit
about how it is sometimes possible to
improve the performance of a sql query
just by changing the way that you write
your sql
and i will show an example of this
and finally one of the keys to nla sql
statements for performance is to
understand how sql server is processing
your query
so i will briefly talk about the most
common operations that you will see in
the execution plan and highlight the
ones that you especially want to watch
out for
so let's start right into the example of
a sql query
that isn't performing quite the way that
it should be
and see how we work through analysing
and fixing this statement in the next
video
you are watching the video of module 2
analysing sql statements for performance
part 2 understanding how sql server will
execute a sql statement
i have a sql select statement here in my
editor window that we are going to use
and see the concepts around execution
plan and how to analyze a sql statement
you can see the output of this statement
in the result pane
and
what this statement is doing is
selecting all of the courses that a
particular student has taken with a
title of the course
the number of the credits
and the grade that the student received
to get this information we need to join
three tables
we need to query the course enrollments
table to get what courses the student
has taken and what grade they received
and then we will need to join through
the course offerings table to get to the
courses table so we can get the course
number and course title and credits
so you might imagine a query like this
being run on a web page that produce a
grade report for an individual student
so i am going to go ahead and run this
query
and we do see that it takes second to
run
so maybe you have identified this query
as something you need to take a look at
and we want to figure out how we can
make this query run faster
so the first step in that process is to
have sql server give us the execution
plan
that it's using to process the query
and to do that we are going to go up to
this button on our toolbar with the
three boxes and a little icon in it
and this is labeled display estimated
execution plan
and so as you can see if i mouse over
over that and the tool tips comes up
you can also use a keyboard shortcut of
control plus l
now clicking this button is not going to
actually execute the statement that is
in the window
it just going to send the statement to
sql server to our sql server to return
back to us the plan that it would use to
run the statement
so let's go ahead and do that
and so now down here
we see in our result pane instead of the
data coming back for this query
we see a graphical representation of the
execution plan
what sql server has done is it taken our
statement and it broken it down into the
individual steps that sql server is
going to have to perform when it
executes this statement
and each of this step is represented by
one of this icon that you can see down
here in the bottom
now you might have a question that how
did sql server arrive at this plan
well
it looked at the tables our statement is
accessing and any index that are on
those tables and what we are trying to
do in our statement
and
it very quickly compared all of the
different options for how our statement
could be processed
and it determined that this set of
operation in this order was the most
efficient one
when we have a statement that we don't
think is performing the way that it
should
the first thing that we want to do is we
want to pull up the execution plan like
this
and understand what step sql server is
performing
and if
any of these steps are inefficient and
time consuming
if there is anything we can do about
those steps to affect them or affect the
overall plan and get them to be more
efficient
this is just like if you are
troubleshooting a slow code in a
language like c sharp or java
you would go and find out what steps are
executed in that program
and figure out if any of those steps was
bottlenecked or could be executed faster
and what you could do speed things up
and really the same thing that we are
going to do here
so in the next video we are going to
understand how to read and understand
the execution plan that sql server has
given us
and that's given us some clue about how
we can make this query run faster
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
part 3 reading and interpreting an
execution plan for an sql statement
let me zoom in on the execution plan to
make this plan easier for us to read
to read an execution plan we want to
work from right to left and from top to
bottom
you can think of this as though the
operations in the right are getting
executed first
and then as we move to the left this
intermediate operations will build upon
the already completed operations
and eventually we will get to this upper
hand corner
which represents our complete statement
actually this isn't quite hundred
percent accurate
since sequel server will parallelize
parts of our statement for us
such that
things aren't strictly sequential
but for analysis purpose it's easiest if
you think of things happening serially
starting from the right and moving to
the left
so we will start out on the right
with this cluster index scan operation
and we can see that on the second line
this operation is occurring against the
course enrollment table
we can also see on the third line
what percentage of the total cost of the
query this particular operation accounts
for
and we see that this is 91 percent in
this case
so that immediately signals to us that
when we get to the point of tuning the
statement
this is an operation that we really
going to want to take a look at
in this case i will go through each
operations in the execution plan
so you can get a feel for how to read
these plans that sql server gives you
but a lot of times what you will do is
you will bring up execution plan and
look for the operations that are
accounting for the highest percentage of
the overall statement cost
and immediately focus it on those so
this cost percentage can really serve as
a quick filter of what you are looking
for if i mouse over any operation i will
get a pop-up tool tip that going to give
me some additional details information
on that particular operation
so we see at the top of the tooltip we
have the name of the operation again
below that we have a little bit of
description of the operation that sql
server give us in this case we want to
remember that a cluster index structure
is a typical way that data in a table is
stored in sql server so the word scan
indicates that sql server is reading the
entire cluster index
so what that means is that in this
operation sql server is reading each and
every row in the course enrollments
table
and that's a table that has 37 lakh rows
in it when you are reading execution
plans
this is actually something that you want
to look for is if you have any cluster
index scan operations on tables that you
know contains a lot of data because what
a cluster index scan really means is
that you are reading all of the rows in
that table and for large tables that of
course is going to be very expensive and
takes a lot of time
so knowing this that we are processing
37 lakh rows in this operation we have a
good idea already of why this particular
operation is accounting for 91 percent
of the cost of this statement
now you might ask what rows are we
trying to find in this table
and that can be answered by looking at
the predicate data on this pop-up
which is down here at the bottom
so you see our where clause for the
statement and what is happening is that
we are trying to find out the rows for
this particular student
but as we just talked about
we are having to look through all of the
rows in the table to do that
we can also get an estimate of how many
rows sql server expect to find in this
operation and that's given by estimate
number of rows value which is shown up
here the way that sql server calculate
this is because sql server keeps some
statistics on each table
in the database and these are statistics
like how many rows are there in the
table and what the rough distribution of
data in that table is
sql server uses that information in
order to form its execution plan and
that's also helpful to us here
because it tells us that sql server is
only expecting to find 45 rows even
though we know that it reading a very
large number of rows from this table the
final item i want to talk about in this
pop-up are these items that are labeled
with the word cost and you can see that
there are four of them here cost is just
a value that sql server used to express
how expensive a particular operation or
entire statements is compared to another
statements or operation
as you see here there is a cpu cost
which reflects how much cpu this
operation is going to use and an i o
cost reflecting how expensive the io is
for this operation
so basically what sql server has done is
it's taken the amount of cpu it thinks
this operation will consume and the
amount of io it's taken those value and
its normalized those amount against a
scale
such that
it can add each of those values together
and get a single value which represents
how expensive this operation is
and that's what we see on this estimated
operator cost line
now we also get a cost for an entire
statement
which if we go over here and we look at
the select in the upper hand left corner
we get we see that the estimate subtree
cost is 12 here
and we can use this value so that we can
compare the relative expense of running
this statement versus other statement
that we have
and that helps guide us about what are
our most expensive sql statement and
which statements that we should tune
first
so let's go ahead and continue to read
this execution plan and understand what
is going on in it
so we just read the course enrollments
table and we got out the records for a
particular students in there
and then
if we come over here to the left we see
this step of parallelism if you are
unaware of the concept parallelism
then i would like to give you a brief
explanation about it
parallelism is a concept in which the
big task is divided into the small task
that runs simultaneously and create
desired result and finally that partial
result of each small task combined into
the final big task
this concept of
parallelism helped to run queries much
faster
ok
now we proceed further in the left
and now we can see the nested loop joint
and we can mouse over this
and from the description it says that we
are going to take each row in the upper
data set and we are going to prop or
investigate the lower data set
in order to get that information
so
this is what is doing our join between
these two tables
if we go back over here
we see that this is the course offering
table
which is down here on the bottom
now this is a cluster index seek
operation
so it means what sql server is doing is
it's actually using the tree structure
of the cluster index in order to find
the data
and as you see here the cost is just one
percent
and if we mouse over this
both of our cost values are very very
low for this operation
but basically what these three
operations here are doing together is
finding the data it needs in course
enrollments and then in joining that
over to course offerings so now we have
an intermediate data set of those two
table combined in the next step here in
nested loops sql server will join the
previous data set of course enrollment
and course offerings and the result data
set after fetching data from the course
table
and in that it again perform parallelism
to generate result
so finally we get up here to the select
box
and this represents our entire statement
we already looked at this
and
this has our entire cost inside of it
and also gives us an estimate number of
rows
now we know that we actually are getting
more rows back
again
the statistic data is just an estimate
the sql server has
but this is basically the procedure that
you use to read an execution plan what
you are going to want to do is move from
right to left and then when you
encounter a join operation
you want to read those
from top to bottom
you can see what each operation is doing
and how it fits it with the operations
around it
and if you want to see more details
then you have to mouse over one of the
operations so you can get that pop-up
box
this is my suggestion to you that you
don't have to analyze each and every
operation but instead you can just focus
on the high cost operations
and that helps you understand where you
want to focus your tuning efforts
in the next video i will demonstrate one
additional technique for analyzing a
statement and that is how we get the
amount of cpu and io that a statement
uses when you actually run the statement
so we will do that next
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
part 4 getting execution statistics for
a sql statement
technique that you will find useful is
to use the set statistics commands in
management studio
so that you can get detailed i o and cpu
statistics about the statements being
run to do this we are just going to run
two commands in our sql editor window
set statistics io on
and set statistics time on and then i am
going to go ahead and execute both of
these commands
so now when i run a statement i am going
to get some detailed information back in
the messages tab
down here in the bottom in the result
pane
so just to be clear to get this detailed
cpu and io data back
you do need to actually execute your
statement
so unlike in the last segment where we
looked at where getting an estimate
execution plan
didn't actually run the statement
this is actually going to run the
statement again sql server
so
you want to be careful with any dml
statements like update or deletes
because those of course would actually
be modified the data in your database
in this case i am just running a select
statement
so i can run that like a normal one
so i will go ahead and do that now
i will make sure that we get the entire
statement here
and i will execute this statement
so now you see that here is our results
and that actually did run a little bit
quicker
and so the reason that ran quicker is
because sql server actually has cached
the data that this query needs in memory
but as we are going to see
if we click over here on the message tab
this statement is still pretty
inefficient
so there are some tuning opportunities
present there
so let's take a look at that
so the first set of items which is right
here tells us how long sql server took
to create an execution plan for our
statement
remember the last part where we talk
about that when sql server gets a sql
statement submitted
it has to break the statements up into
the individual operations that is going
to run
and this is the amount of time that it
took
in this case sql server already has an
execution plan cached in memory that it
would use so this actually didn't take
any time at all in this case
next we have some io information for the
database object sql server has to read
in order to process our statement
as we see there were three tables in
this case the data needed to be read
from
and the important number that we want to
pay attention to here are these logical
reads
a logical read is when sql server has to
read a page either from memory or disk
in order to process the statement
so it really helps to indicate how much
data is having to be processed in order
to run the statement
we see here that the course enrollment
stable that was over 12 000 logical
reads
that had to occur
and this is because as we saw in the
last segment sql server is reading the
entire table to find the data that we
need
each logical read is a page of sql
server and remember a page is 8 kb in
size
so 12 000 times 8 kb we can see that's
quite a bit of data that sql server is
having to process through here
if we move down to the last section it
gives us the amount of cpu it took to
actually execute the statement
and how long that process took now
sometimes you will see in this section
an amount of cpu that is larger than the
elapsed time
and what's happening in those cases is
that sql server has used some parallel
execution for at least part of your
statement
as such
since your cpu on multiple cores
we can use more cpu time than what it
actually took for the statement to run
overall
these commands do gives us a good
picture of the amount of resources up on
the database server that are being used
by this statement
of course what we are aiming for is that
for each one of our statement we want to
minimize this number and so that i
myself do
is i really focus on this number of
logical reads
a high number of logical reads often
indicates a statement is inefficient
because it's reading a bunch of data
that ultimately it's going to filter out
and throw away in some other operation
in the statement
i also find that when you are reading a
lot of data in terms of a lot of logical
reads
that tends to consume a lot of cpu and
ultimately those statements take longer
to process
so between the execution plan we saw in
the last part and this execution
statistic we have a pretty good idea of
what's going on in this statement
so
in the next video we are going to
actually start working on this and
tuning this statement to make it run
more efficiently
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
part 5 improving statement performance
by adding an index
i bought the execution plan for our sql
statement back
and by now we realized it this operation
here the cluster index scan that is
responsible for most of the cost of the
sql statement
as we discussed this operation is
reading all 37 lakh rows which is 12 000
pages from the table
just to find out the handful of rows
that we need for one student
so there is a lot of waste here
so
what we can do now
well actually you have probably noticed
that sql server has given us a hint and
it's telling us that we really need to
create an index on this table
so i am going to right click on this
recommendation and go to the missing
index details so that we can see exactly
what is telling us
in this case the suggestion is to create
an index on the student id column in the
course enrollments table
and that exactly that we want to do if
we look back at our statement we are
using the student id column as a filter
so we can find just one particular
student and if we think about this table
in the larger context of our application
and how it might be used it is going to
be pretty typical use case that we have
a student id and we want to find out of
all the courses that a student is
enrolled in so creating an index on the
student id column of the course
enrollments table will allow us to
quickly search for course enrollments by
student id
and that's make a lot of logical sense
so let's go ahead and get this index
created
so i just need to uncomment this
and then go up here and i will have to
give this index a name
and this is just how i like to name
indexes
you actually can give it valid name that
you want to
and then i am going to go ahead and
create this index
and so that will take a few seconds here
and there we go
and so
now let's head back to our sql statement
and we will get a new execution plan and
see how things have changed
okay
we can see out here that the cluster
index scan operation has been replaced
with an index seek
and then a key lookup
so
if we go and we look at this here
we see the seek predicate now is on the
student id
so
we are using the index to look up the
students and notice the cost of this
operation
it's down there around 0.003
it looks like
so this is much much cheaper than the
10.92 value that we saw before now as we
talk about in the module 1 part 6 at
this course
all this does here it lookups just the
information in the index
and then we have to go to the table to
get the actual data for those rows
so
that's what this key lookup is here and
it's doing that with a nested loop join
and so this is what actually going up
and looking up the data in the table
so that we can get the data to come out
here
so we can see that the rest of the plan
looks basically the same if we do look
at the overall query though we see that
our estimate cost now is around 0.207
right in here
remember before it was way up over 12.01
so we have seen a significant saving
here
so
i am going to go ahead and i am going to
run this query again
and i still have the statistics turned
on
so we can see the number of i o and the
amount of cpu that it's using
so i will run this and look at the
message tab and you can see here first
of all on logical rates before from the
course enrollments table we had over 12
000 logical reads
and now we are down to 134 only
so by using that index we are traversing
the tree structure of the index
we are doing much much less work before
and that's accounting for our statement
being more efficient
you see down here at the bottom of the
sql server execution times we are
actually showing zero both for cpu
and ellipse time
in reality it's probably isn't zero cpu
time or zero ellipse time
it just below the measurement threshold
so again now we have a very efficient
statement
so i am going to take this result and
put them on a slide so we can discuss
them
i have summarized the result on this
slide
and as you can see the improvement is
dramatic
now you might be thinking that the
elapsed time only improved by
approximately 100 milliseconds
but remember i am the only user on my pc
running sql server on an actual
production system you may have hundreds
of user running statement at a time
and you may also be dealing with the
data sets that are much much larger than
what i have in my sample database
so on an actual production system the
efficiency of the first statement would
certainly result in a less scalable
system and would probably also result in
the longer wait times for users
as this inefficient query used up all
the resources causing contention on the
server
i have actually seen this before where a
single query that was doing a full table
scan brought an entire system down
because the query was run often enough
to consume all the cpu on the database
server which then slow down every other
sql statement in the application
because those statements were having to
wait to get on the cpu
so it is really a key to keep all the
sql statements in our application
running as efficiently as possible
especially for statement that are
frequently run in our application
with that in mind let's look at another
sql statement that we need to tune in
the next video
but in this case the answer is not to
add an index
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statement for performance
part 6 rewriting sql statements for
improved performance
i have another statement in my editor
window and this statement is designed to
get all of the courses section that no
students are sign up for so
you might imagine a university running a
query like this at the start of a
semester to find out any courses section
that need to be cancelled
to accomplish this this query is doing a
left join
and then looking for any course
enrollment records that are null
because that indicates that no one
signed up for the class
we can see the result in the lower pane
and we see that we do have a couple of
sections then no one has signed up for
what we are really interested is the
execution plan for this query so let's
take a look at that
if i mouse over the overall query here
we will see that there is an
overall cost of 8 and if we look at the
execution plan
it looks like that cost is being driven
by the index seek lookups occurring
against the index in the course
environments table down here at the
bottom
so what is happening in these three
operations here is that sql server is
reading all of the offerings for the
courses in a current semester
and then through this nested loop join
it is probing an index on the course
enrollments table
ix course enrollments course offering id
and looking up how many enrollments
there are for that course
the issue here is that sql server is
looking for all the enrollments for each
course
when we really only need to know if
there is any student enroll in the
course
since we are looking up all the
environments these operations turns out
to be pretty expensive
making our whole query pretty expensive
now in this case the answer is not an
index
but instead for us to change how we
write this query
so let's take an alternate approach
this version of the query uses the not
exist clause to look for any code
offerings that don't have any records in
the course environments table so
let's go ahead and run this version of
query
and we see we get the same answer as
before
so now let's take a look at the
execution plan
and we see
if we mouse over this query
that our overall cost for this version
of this statement is quite a bit lower
down around 0.85
and if we look at the entire plan
we notice this top operation here
and if we mouse over this
we see the description tell us that we
are just going to return the first few
rows from the previous operation
and looking down at the bottom we see
that the expression is top one
so it is actually just getting the first
row from the index seek operation which
is over here to the right
so what this means is that sql server is
reading all of the course offerings just
like it was doing before
but
then in the nested loop join what it is
able to do is able to prop the index
looking for any single row that matches
the course offering id number
so sql server doesn't have to read the
data for every student enrolled in the
course
it is just looking to see if at least
one student is in the course and that's
more efficient than getting the data for
each and every student android
so think of this like you are searching
an array of values
if you can jump out of this search when
you find any value that matches
what you are searching for
that's more efficient than having to
find every value that matches
because once you find the first matching
value of course you can jump out of the
search functions and that's essential
what's happening here
now i also want to point out that sql
server is giving me a create index
recommendation here
but in this case i am actually choosing
to ignore this suggestion
the recommendation here is basically sql
server wants me to create an index on
the course offerings table that contains
every column of the
table
so
effectively i will be duplicating all of
the data in the table
we will talk in the upcoming module
about why this is not a good idea but i
want to point out this out so that you
understand when sql server gives you
this recommendation
you want to be sure and analyze
what sql server is telling you
and that it makes sense and don't simply
create an index because sequels are made
in a recommendation
the main point of the two queries we
just looked at
though
is that something the way to improve the
performance of sql statement is to
rewrite the statement in a different way
a sub query can be written as a join or
you might change a join to a sub query
and as we just showed sometimes using
the where exist or where not exist
clause can improve a plan because sql
server can satisfy the condition with
any record that matches the condition
instead of having to read all matching
records from a table
so keep these options in mind when you
tune your sql statements
in many cases in the modern version of
sql server the query optimizer is smart
enough to find the best execution plan
regardless of how you write your
statement
but there are few cases where writing
your statement a different way will help
the query optimizer find a more
efficient plan
so keep this option in mind
so in the next video i am going to
summarize the common execution plan
operations for better understanding
so let's jump ahead
you are watching the video of module 2
analyzing sql statements for performance
part 7 common execution plan operations
we have looked through a couple of
execution plan so i want to summarize
some of the common operations that you
are going to see
when you are accessing the data either
in a table or in an index these are the
typical data access operations you are
going to see
i am not going to read through each one
of these
but i do want to point out there are
really two different types of operations
that are listed here
and those are scan operations and seek
operations
what you need to remember is that a scan
operation means that sql server is
reading the entire data structure that
is acting on
so either an entire table or an index
and that is of course going to be
expensive for any table or index that
has a large amount of data in it
seek operations on the other hand use
the tree structure that the data is laid
out in
so they can be very efficient to find
the data that they are looking for
the takeaway is when we are looking at
an execution plan
and we see scan operations on large
table we want to ask why a scan
operation is being used and how we can
get sql server to change over to using a
seek operation
this slide summarize the join operations
that you will see sql server perform
we have seen the nested loop joined
quite a bit and the implementation is
exactly like the name implies
mud join tends to be used more
infrequently because the data for both
data sets need to be in a sorted order
for sql server to use the join
if the data for one of the data sets is
not already sorted correctly
then sql server will have to perform a
sort operation first
and then perform the join
if the data is already sorted mud join
tends to be very efficient but if sql
server has to first sort the data to use
this operation then one of the outer
join operations tends to be more
efficient
the last type of join is the hash match
which is sometimes referred to a hash
join
this is used when sql server needs to
join two large data sets and there isn't
already some sort of key
like an index key that can be used to
join the data sets together
so what sql server does is it builds a
hash table on a smaller data sets on a
join key and then iterates through the
larger data sets probing the hash table
for matching values
typically when you see a hash match join
it is relatively expensive operation
build a hash table in memory takes time
and it can take a lot of
memory plus as we said sql server will
only use a hash match when large data
sets are involved
so when you see a hash match join you
want to ask yourself why a hash match
join is required
first is that any way to narrow down the
data set that are being joined together
so that not as much as data need to be
joined
for example you might look to see if you
can include a more restrictive where
clause in your statement to cut down on
the size of the data that need to be
joined
second a hash match join indicates there
is no existing key like an index key
that can be used for join
many times this indicates that you are
missing an index on one of the foreign
relationship between your tables
so adding an index may be appropriate
again in the next module we will be
talking quite a bit about creating good
indexes including what columns in a
table you want to ensure to index and
this usually includes any foreign key
columns that your table has
there are many operations an execution
plan can contain but covering each and
every one would take a very long time
and lead to some very boring video for
you to watch
if you do encounter an operation that
you need to understand more about that
what is provided in the description that
sql server management studio gives to
you
then i would suggest you to take a look
at this book on sql server execution
plans you can use the url shown on the
screen
and i will include this url in the
description box for your convenience
and as you see the ebook can be
downloaded for free
and you can actually don't ever have to
register it
this is a direct download link here
the book contains a lot of material on
how to read execution plan as well as
detail information on most of the
operation that can be contained within
an execution plan
as a developer you are probably not
going to sit down and read this book
from cover to cover but it is a useful
reference to have around for the times
that you don't quite understand why
something is working the way you think
that it should and need a little bit
more in-depth explanation of how an
operation work so with that let's go
ahead and summarize everything we have
learned in this module and wrap things
up you are watching the video of module
2 analyzing sql statements for
performance part 8 module summary
in this video let's summarize what we
have discussed in this module about
analyzing sql statements for performance
when you have a statement you need to
analyze the first step you are going to
take is to get execution plan of that
statement
getting the execution plan doesn't
actually run the statement
but just tell us how sql server will
process the statement so we can analyze
the plan for any performance bottlenecks
once you get the plan you want to read
the plan from right to left and when you
encounter a join operation you have to
read from top to bottom
so you analyze the operation at the top
of the join first and then the operation
on the bottom
the statement in each individual
operation is going to have a cost value
assigned to it
and cost is simply a single value that
combines together both the amount of cpu
and are you required by the statement or
the operation
with any statement we want to focus our
attention on the operation that have
relatively high cost
because a high cost means that those
operations are consuming lot of
resources and consequently that will
take longer time to complete
at a statement level we can use the cost
value to compare the relative expense of
executing different statements within
our application
and again we want to focus our attention
on the high cost statement our
application runs
sql server can also give us a detailed
execution statistics about each
statement we run if we use the set
statistics command in management studio
what you want to pay special attention
is the number of logical reads
as each logical read represent an 8 kb
page of data
a high number of logical reads often
represents an inefficient operation that
is having to read a lot of data to find
the piece of data that is really needed
once we understand what operations are
causing the statement to be slow we can
start to tune the statement to improve
its performance
we looked at one case where the solution
was to add an index
as this allowed sql server to use the
tree structure of the index to find the
data it needed
rather than scanning the entire table
we also look at the example where we
change our sql statement and this is
another solution you may want to
consider sometimes changing a sub query
to a join or may be using the exist
keyword helps sql server find a more
efficient execution plan
you can also do a general evaluation of
your statement and see if there is an
opportunity to include more selective
where clause
or possibly change your statement to
where it's asking the question you want
answer in a slightly different way
what getting an execution plan allows
you to do to see the individual steps
that have to be executed to run your
statement and to find which statements
are most costly
then you can focus on this operation to
see what you can do
to make these operations more efficient
one of the most important tool we have
is to create a good index on our table
that the statement in our application
will use
so we will dive into the topic of how to
create effective indexes in the next
module
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective index part 1 module
introduction
probably the most important step you can
take to make sure the sql in your
application performs well
for which we have to create effective
indexes on the table in your database
and that is exactly what we are going to
cover in this module
we are going to start off with a
revision on index terminology just to
make sure that some definitions are
fresh in your mind as we go through this
module
second we will discuss what column in
your database you want to create index
and why
then we are going to turn our attention
to two characteristics you need to pay
attention in order to make sure
that your indexes are effective
and those are the order of the columns
in the index and the selectivity of your
indexes
we will move on and talk about covering
indexes and include columns and when
those are useful
and then we will discuss the effect of
using a function in your where clause
and how these affect if sql server can
use an index for your statement
after that we will see the concept of
over indexing which is when too many
indexes are created on a table which
slows down dml statements like insert
and updates against the table
and then we will wrap up with the
discussion about index recommendation
provided to you by sql server and some
advice on how to interpret those we have
a lot of material to cover so let's go
ahead and review some index terminology
in the next video
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 2 index
terminology refresher
before we go ahead i want to take your
just few minutes and refresh on some
index terminology so these definitions
are refresh in your mind as we go
through this material
when you look at the sql server
documentation or any writings on sql
server you are going to see the terms
cluster index and non-cluster index
a cluster index is the structure that
sql server stores the data in the table
typically a cluster index is built on
the primary key of the table so the data
in the table is arranged in the tree
structure organized by the primary key
so
when we are talking about cluster index
we are really talking about the
structure that contains the data for the
table
and how the data is physically stored in
a table on disk
any other index you create on a table is
going to be non cluster index a
non-cluster index is built over one or
more columns of the table
which define the index key
and then the index also stored a row
pointer to where in the table the
matching rows for that index key are
located
in this module when i talk about indexes
i am really talking about these non
cluster indexes
because you are going to need to query
the data in your tables by columns other
than the primary key and creative
effective non-cluster index is really
the key to achieving good performance
when you are doing so
there are two types of operations that
can be performed against the key
a scan operation or a c corporation a
scan operation is going to read the
entire index to find the matching values
it is looking for
whereas a seek operation is going to
traverse the tree structure of the index
in order to find it matches
when we say a sql statement is using an
index
what we really mean is that the
statement is conducting a seek operation
against the index
because
this is much more efficient than a scan
operation
and is really using the index and as it
is designed to be used
so when you examine operations against
indexes in your execution plans
you really want to be looking for the
seek operations
if instead you are seeing scan
operations while sql server is accessing
the index
it isn't really what you want from a
performance point of view
so
you want to examine why you are getting
a scan operation
and not a seek operation
now that we have refreshed on some
fundamentals
so let's talk about what columns we
should be thinking about indexing in our
database to deliver good application
performance
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 3 what
should i index in my database
we saw an example in the last module
where we dramatically improved the
performance of a sql statement by adding
an index to a table
by adding the correct index to our
database we are going a long way to
assure that our application's data
access layer will perform well so
what we want to do is to understand what
tables and columns we want to be
indexing in our database from the start
so we can avoid any performance issues
in our applications
there are really two categories of
columns we want to make sure to index
the first set of columns we want to make
sure and index are those that are being
used in where clauses of our sql
statements
whether we are running a select update
or delete statement the where clause is
how sql server locates the rows we are
interested in for our statement
having an index on the columns used in
the where clause means that sql server
will be able to find the rows needed by
the statement
by using an index seek operation which
is very fast and efficient
now it is very possible that different
statements in our application will
contain different where clauses
when accessing the same table like we
see here
in this case we would want to create an
additional index to support each
statement
so
in this case we would create a second
index over email address
you can imagine a search form in your
application that allows the user to
search for students by their name or by
their email address
and these two indexes would correlate to
those two different use cases
now you might also want to search for a
student by the student id
but in this case student id is the
primary key of the students table
and sql server automatically creates an
index on the primary key columns of the
data
so we don't need to do that by ourself
but for any other way that we are going
to be looking up the data on a table
we are going to have an index on those
column in the where clause that we are
using to look the data up
the second category of columns that we
want to make sure and index are any
foreign key columns in our table
there are two reasons for this
first
when we join two tables together sql
server will look up the rows in one
table and then find the corresponding
rows in the second table
and to do this sql server is going to be
searching for those matching rows in the
second table by their foreign key values
second when we query data in our
application we are often traversing this
foreign key relationship to load the
data that our application needs
we saw an example of this in the last
module where we had a query that load
the grades for a particular student by
their student id
if we think about this query in the
larger context of the application we
probably had some page in our
application that the student used a
login and once logged in our application
kept track of the student's id number
during the login session
then as we navigate the various pages in
our application the student id number
will be feed into various queries like
the one that we see on our screen
to get the data related to the student
if you have written any data access code
you realize it it is quite common to
query across the foreign keys in the
table like this
is what we are really doing is squaring
across parent child relationships
so now
that we know that what columns we should
be looking at indexing
let's understand in the next video what
makes an index effective
so that sql server can actually use it
in our sql statements
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 4 by
index column order matters
in any database some of our indexes will
have multiple columns
and the order of the columns in the
index determine if sql server will be
able to use the index and how sql server
can use the index
so
let's look at an example to understand
this
i have this index that you see on your
screen already created on my applicants
table
and you see the query i want to run in
the editor window as well just below
the query is trying to find an applicant
by their last name with their state
so you might imagine a query like this
being run from a sort of search form in
one of your application to let an
admission counselor finds an applicant
what i want to do is to point out that
in the index the column order is first
name last name and then state and in the
where clause of the query i have just
the last name and the state specified
which is the second and third column of
the index
so
let's get an execution plan and see how
sql server will process this statement
what i want to focus your attention on
is this operation here
this is the scan operation against our
index and notice that i said scan
operation
a scan operation like this is actually
going to read the entire index
so
this is not going to use the tree
structure of the index to find the
matching keys
but instead reach each and every key of
the index in order to find the matching
values
so
this is like a big linear search through
all of the keys of the index
what we want to see here is a seek
operation
because that would mean that sql server
is using the tree structure that the
index is organized by to find the
matching keys
and this would be much more efficient
the reason why sequel server is using a
scan operation rather than a c
corporation in this case is because our
where clause does not include the first
column
of the index
which in this case is the first name
column
if you don't include this leading column
of the index in your where clause sql
server will either not be able to use
the index at all or it may have to scan
the entire index like we see here
which is not very efficient and i will
show you some stats in this case to
prove it
so if we mouse over the query
we will be able to see the cost for the
entire query
and that's about 4.3
and now i have already actually set the
set statistics io and time on so if run
this query we will get additional
execution stats and we can see that this
query is taking over 2600 logical reads
to process
and that includes read both against the
table and the indexes on the table
so this really isn't very efficient
so let's think about what we can do to
fix this
we could modify our query and make the
user include a first name value
but this is not really very realistic
the reason our user didn't include a
first name value is probably because
they don't know it
so we can't really require them to
provide a value that they don't know
what we can do though is we can change
the order of the columns in our index
so let's do that
so what i am going to do is i am going
to drop the current index
and there we go
and now i am going to recreate an index
and in this case i am going to have the
last name column in the first position
of this index and the first name column
in the second position
so i am going to go ahead and create
this
and now i will take this query and i am
going to get the execution plan again
we see now that the operation here has
changed to a index seek operation and
that is what we want because it means
that sql server is traversing the tree
structure of the index to find the
matching index keys
so this is going to be a lot more
efficient and we can prove that by
looking at some of the stats
so first we are going to look at the
cost here of the overall query
and we see now that's down at 1.4
much more efficient than before
and if we run this query again we see
that now we are only doing 188 logical
grids
whereas before
we are doing over 2600
so again
this is much more efficient
and the reason why is because when we
have those columns in the index in the
right order
such that sql server can use the index
then sql server is having to process a
lot less data because it can directly
find the data that it needs
this has important implications for when
we create multi-column indexes in terms
of what order we should put the columns
in
what we want to do is to think about how
our user query the data in the table
we are creating the index on and what
different combinations of columns are
used in the where clauses of these
queries
then
with each combinations of column we want
to put the most frequently included
columns as the first column of the index
the second most frequently used column
in the second column of the index and so
on
so in the first example of this slide
since the last name column is always
included when doing and search by name
it is in the first position in the index
first name is frequently included so it
is in the second position and only
sometimes the state is included so that
is in the last position
if the user only includes the last name
in the query or the last name and the
first name that's okay sql server can
still use this index because we have the
leading column of the index and these
columns are selective enough which we
will talk about in a moment
now our user might also need to search
this table for data in a complete
different fashion as well
in this case by the state and the city
that an applicant is from
so in this case we need to create a
second index on the table because we
need the state column to be in the lead
position so sql server can use this
second index so what you will end up
with on your table is an index that is
target at supporting each of the
different ways that your user of your
application access data on this table
so it's pretty typical that on the key
tables of your application you will
probably have from two to four different
indexes to support these different query
combinations
the next step in the process though is
to make sure that the index are
selective enough so that sql server can
use them
and we will look at this in the next
video
you are watching this video of module 3
building effective indexes part 5 index
selectivity
the second factor that governs how
effective an index will be is the
selectivity of the index
and selectivity is simply a way of
saying how many or how few rows there
are in the table for each key value in
the index
for our indexes to be used by sql server
and to be effective at speeding up the
performance we want our indexes to be as
selective as possible
that is each value of the index key
should only correspond to a few rows in
a table
or perhaps even only one row let's see
why this matters we know that when sql
server uses an index it traverses the
tree structure of the index to finding
the matching keys in the index when it
finds the matching key or keys it will
read from the index the value of the row
identifiers for the rows that matches
those index keys
in a typical table this row identifiers
are just the primary key values of the
matching rows
then sql server takes this row
identifier and look up the actual rows
in the table
which as we have talked about is usually
another tree structure called a cluster
index
so
if the index is selective we will only
find a few matching values in the index
that we have to look up in the table
so we are doing a small number of i o
operations overall but what if our index
isn't very selective what if for the
index key we look up we get back several
thousand matches
well then we are going to have come over
to the table and look up each and every
one of those rows
so that is several thousand times we are
going to have to look up data in this
table
and since our data is probably randomly
distributed throughout the table
we are going to end up reading most if
not all of the pages in the table anyway
so in this case it is actually more
efficient for sql server not to use the
index and just to read the entire table
anyway
this way sql server doesn't have to
incur the i o of reading the index
because the index isn't really helpful
in terms of narrowing down what data sql
server needs to find
when we say that we want our indexes to
be selective
what we are really saying is that we
want them to really help sql server
target exactly where the data is that we
need to find
and to do that we want our indexes to
have a high number of unique key values
compared to the total number of rows in
the table let's jump into management
studio and look at some example of this
i have created the index at the top of
the screen on the students table and i
am going to run the query that's at the
bottom of the text editor
but before i do i am going to give you
some statistics about the students table
there are about 1 lakh 20 000 rows in
the students table
and in terms of unique first and last
name combinations there are about 1 lakh
7 000 of those
so we can tell from those numbers the
combination of last and first name that
is index is built on is a pretty
selective
criteria while we do have multiple
students that have the same first and
last name overall this criteria is
pretty unique the calculation that sql
server does internally in its statistics
to determine selectivity is more complex
than a simple ratio
but
this ratio gives us a good idea of how
unique the values in this index are
and i find that for everyday use this
simple ratio works pretty well
so we would expect that sql server would
use this index when it executes the
query that we see we will get the
execution plan to see that indeed that
is the case
and so we see here that sql server is
doing an index seek operation against
that index
so indeed our index is being used
if i mouse over the index seek operation
you see that sql server is expecting
about 25 values in the index would match
this criteria
and again sql server is calculating this
value based on the statistics it has on
the table and on the index
so its calculation is more sophisticated
than our simple ratio
but this is what sql server is expecting
to happen then it's going to come down
to this key lookup operation and look up
each one of those rows and if we mouse
over the key lookup operation we again
see that value that's about 25 in terms
on the number of estimated executions
so at this threshold sql survey has
calculated that using the index is the
right decision because performing the
estimated 25 lookups on the table is
going to be much faster than reading the
entire table
now if we run this query we did actually
get back 4 rows of the data
so this lookup operation actually would
be executed 4 times not 25 times
the point is though that the lookup
operation is only executed a handful of
times and we only need to read a few
data pages from the table
so we are being very targeted in the
data that we read which is what an index
is supposed to give us
let's look at the different situation
though when we don't have a selective
index and see what sql server does in
that situation
if i go over to this other tab that i
have here
we see again that we have another index
on the students table that i have
created
and this index is just over us states
run the query that you see here in the
bottom of the text editor
and what that's going to do is it's
going to look up all the students that
live in appleton wisconsin
remember we have about 1 lakh 20 000
rows of students in the table
and in terms of states abbreviation
there are actually 52 distinct value in
our students table
so we have the 50 states the district of
columbia
and maybe we have some students from
puerto rico and another u.s territories
if we divide 1 lakh 20 000 rows by 50 we
get about 2400 matches per index in this
case
now this max isn't perfect because of
course there are some states like
california where proportionately we are
going to have many many more students
than in the small states like wyoming
but for a rough estimated to start with
what this is telling us is that for
having an index just on the state column
it is not going to be very selective
because we are actually going to get
about 2400 students back
so let's go ahead and get the execution
plan of this query
and see what sql server does with this
statement what we see here is that sql
server actually isn't using this index
on the state column in the query
and that is because when sql server look
at its statistics
we would be getting a lot of matches
back from that index
and when you read all of those matches
out of the index and then go and look up
all of those values in the table that
actually was going to be more expensive
than just reading the entire table
direct so sql server not using our index
is really telling us that in sql
server's eyes the index isn't that
helpful because it's not selective
enough
now you might say that i am not sure i
believe that
i think that the index would still be
more efficient
so what i am going to do is i am going
to force sql server to use the index on
this table
and i am going to demonstrate to you
that actually the sql server optimizer
has made the right choice here
so to do this i am going to modify our
query to use a database hint and what
this hint is going to do is going to
tell sql server that i want to use that
index
and normally i strongly recommend that
you avoid using hints in your
application
as today the sql optimizer included with
sql server is very very good
and it's almost always come with the
correct answer in the most efficient way
to execute any statement
in 99.9 percent of the cases today the
sql optimizer comes with the right
answer so the only way i could use a
hint in a production application
is
if it was instructed to do so by
microsoft support or i want to
demonstrate something like i am going to
do now
so we have our hint in there and now
once again i am going to get our
estimated execution plan
and we see now a sql server using the
index
but if we mouse over this index we see
that sql server thinks that it is going
to get back from the index over 2300
matching rows
and if we go down to the key lookup
operation once again we are going to
have to look up 2300 different values in
the table
and this is going to turn out to be very
expensive
in fact
then just scanning the entire student
table i did run both version of this
query prior to recording
one without the hint and one with the
hint
so i could summarize the stats and show
them to you
which i am doing here
what you can see here is that by forcing
sql server to use the index
that indeed is more expensive
and what this is driven by is the fact
that by just having the index on the
state column that is not selective
enough
so if we force sql server to use the
index it's actually having to read and
process more data then if it just read
the entire table directly
this is an important point many times
someone will create the index and they
think that the index they created is
going to speed up the things
but when they look sql server isn't even
using the index
as
we are saying in this case
sql server is making the right decision
not to use the index because using the
index would be more expensive
and the reason why is because of
selectivity
because sql server has to read a large
part of the index and then conduct a
large number of lookup operations that's
accounting for roughly 3500 extra
logical ios that have to be read and
processed by sql server so the answer
here is we need to make our index more
selective so let's do that
we are going to go ahead and drop this
index and then we are going to create a
more selective index
which is both over state and city
in terms of unique combinations for city
and state together there are about 13
thousands of rows
so we are in a much better place in
terms of selectivity for this index so
let's get this created
now we will go ahead and get the
execution plan again for our query
and actually we have to get rid of our
hint in order to make this work because
that index does not exist anymore
and we see now with this more selective
index sql server is able to use the
index
because we see this index seek operation
here
if we mouse over this we see now sql
server is expecting to get back about 20
rows in reality it's actually going to
get a few more than that
but because this index is more selective
it's something that can be used by sql
server because we are doing a better job
of targeting the data that we want
one of the takeaways from this is that
if we have a column that's not very
selective by itself that doesn't mean
that we can't use the column in the
index
it means that we probably need to be
using that column in conjunction with
other columns in our index
and
if we need to make sure that the
combinations of column together is
selected selectivity is really important
concept when we start looking at our
indexes and the where clauses of our
statements
so let's look in the next video at some
other ways in which selectivity matters
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 6
like clauses and index selectivity
one special case i want to talk about
with regards to indexes and selectivity
is when you use a like clause in your
sql statement
first you need to know that if you use
this percentage sign which is the
wildcard character at the front of the
value in the like clause
then sql server will not be able to use
an index for that column
remember the key in index are in sorted
order
and by having a leading wildcard
character in your search value sql
server isn't able to use the sorted
order of the data to take its advantage
so in this case sql server will have to
resort to some sort of scan operation
either of the entire index or of the
entire table
when the wildcard character is used
somewhere else in the like value of your
statement
as we see here
this has an impact on the selectivity of
your index
basically only the characters to the
left of the percentage sign counts in
terms of selectivity for the statement
and the index
so in this case maybe i am not sure if
the last name of the applicant i am
looking for is harris or harrison so i
am using the wildcard character to
search and try to find out the right
applicant
and i am doing the same thing for the
first name
but in this case i am only know that the
first name starts with the letter t
if we get the execution plan for this
statement we see that we will still able
to use the index
because
we have specified enough characters in
the value that we are searching for
but this is still selective enough
but let's look at what happened if i
trim down the value that we are
searching for in the last name to just a
couple of characters
and i will run the execution plan again
and now we see that sql server is doing
a scan operation of the table
it is not able to use the index and the
reason why is because we haven't
provided enough information here
that we can use the index
so really our query just isn't selective
enough here
the reason i bring this up is because
many times i see search pages in
applications that don't enforce any sort
of minimum requirements on the user in
terms of the data that they must supply
now sql server will happily run this
statement for you
they are just going to take a lot of
resources and they are going to take a
lot of time to finish so selectivity is
really a two-way street
first we want to make sure that our
indexes are selective
second we want to make sure that we are
including specific enough criteria for
our where clause of our sql statements
such that our statements are selective
and those statement will be able to use
the indexes that we have created in our
databases
this is where we have to use our
knowledge of how the user is searching
for and accessing data to design good
indexes
and enforces reasonable constraint on
how the user is going to search for data
in our application
as developers we have a good
understanding of how our applications
are trying to access our data
and we have a good understanding of what
the data in our database is
so it is really just a matter of
combining this knowledge together so we
have good indexes in our databases
and we are writing sql statements in our
application that can take advantage of
those indexes
in the next video we are going to talk
about how using functions in the where
clauses of your statement affect sql
servers ability to use an index
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 7
how functions in the where clause affect
indexes
something you want to be aware of is
that if you have a function on the left
side or column side in your where clause
sql server will not be able to use an
index on the table
so you see here that i have an index on
a table over
email address
however looking at my query on the left
hand side of the where clause where we
have the column definition
you can see that in this case i am using
a couple of different functions to
compute the value of just the local part
of the email address
meaning everything left of the address
sign
in the email address
if you have any sort of function over
here on the left hand side of the where
clause processing the value in the
column
sql server is not going to be able to
use a regular index created over the
column
like we see
has been created up here
if we look down at the execution plan we
can see that is the case
because we see that sql server is doing
a scan of the index not a seek operation
so this query isn't going to perform
nearly as well
the reason why this is happening is
because what is sorted in the index are
the actual email address values
not the computed values
so what sql server has to do is to run
this function in real time while the
query is executing to create those
computed values
and then
it can do the comparison
and so to do that you are going to incur
some processing cost and not have a very
fast query
so
you want to keep this in mind whenever
you see a function like this operating
on a column value in the where clause of
one of your queries
if this is something that you really
need to do in your application
though there is a technique
we can use to address this situation
what we are going to do is we are going
to add a computed column to the table
and then we are going to create an index
over that computed column
and in doing so sql server will be able
to use that index over the computed
column
so let's do that
so first i am going to use alter table
statement in order to create the
computed column
so you can see in this statement i have
that same formula with those two
functions
i could use any functions i want to here
even as user defined function
the only thing that i need to remember
is in order to create an index over this
computed column
the expression that i put in here has to
be deterministic
that is it always has to return the same
value for the same inputs
so let's go ahead and get this computed
column created
and now that the column is created
i actually can query the value back out
and i will show those to you
if we scroll over here to the right
we can see here in our computed column
over here on the right
and at this point what sql server is
doing is it's just calculating the value
on the fly
when we request this rows out of the
table in our query
hence the name computed column
what we can do now though is we can
create an index over this column
so let's do that
so you see the create index syntax looks
just like any other index
that we might create
what will happen though is when we run
this create index statement is that sql
server is going to compute all of the
values of this computed column for each
row of the table
and it's going to store those computed
values in the index
so let's go ahead and get this index
created
and there we go
so now we are going to go back up to our
original query and we are going to get
the execution plan for that again
if i can select the right thing and we
see now sql server is able to use this
new index that we have created over the
computed column
and i will mouse over this
so you can see that it is using indeed
that index
and the reason why is because the
formula in the left hand side of our
where clause matches the formula of the
computed column value that the index was
created over
so
what do you want to remember is to be on
the lookout for any type of function or
expression in your where clauses of your
sql statements on that left hand side of
the where clause expression
because those won't be able to use
regular indexes on your table
however if you do need to be able to
search for data using a computed value
then you can use the technique that i
have just shown you here
where
you first create a computed column on
the table
and then you create an index over that
computed column
and that will allow your statement to
use an index
and consequently perform much faster
we have covered the fundamental aspects
of indexes but there is more to learn
about
so we will continue our discussion by
talking about including columns and
covering index next you are watching the
video of module 3 building effective
indexes part 8
include columns and covering indexes
if you take a look at the sql server
documentation or some of the index
recommendation you get back from
management studio you are going to see
this index with the keyword include
so let's understand what is going on
here
the include keyword lets you specify
that one or more columns values should
be stored in the index with the index
key
but they are not part of the index key
so this include columns can't be used by
sql server when it searches the index
and they don't affect how sql server
will lay the index data out in the tree
structure
they will just have their values stored
with the index
the reason why this can be useful is
because we can create what is called a
covering index by using these values
normally when sql server uses an index
it looks up the index keys in the index
to get an row pointer to where the data
is in the table
and then it has to perform a key lookup
operation to get the actual raw data out
of the table
and we have seen several example of this
a covering index is a term used when sql
server can get all of the data it needs
for a query from an index itself and it
doesn't need to perform the key lookup
operation there are two factors at play
here
one notice that we are not using a
select star in our query
but i am spelling out exactly what
columns i want and two notice that all
of these columns are in the index
either as an index key or as an include
column
so sql server does not need to go find
the actual row in the table to read the
data
because it has everything that it needs
right here in the index
and we can see that down here in our
execution plan
because we noticed that we have the
index seek operation
but no corresponding key look of
operation like we have seen before
because in this case we have already all
the data that we need
if there is just one column that we
don't have the data for in the index
sql server would have to perform the
lookup operation on the table
and i can demonstrate that for you if i
add the telephone column to this query
and now i will get the execution plan
for the query again
now since telephone is needed by the
query and it's not part of the index the
index is not a covering index for this
query
and sql server has to go to the table to
get that value
if we take out telephone and run our
execution plan again we see again we
just need the index to fulfill the needs
of this query
sometimes you will have a query like
this where you only need one or maybe
two columns that are not in the index
and that you are having to go to the
table to look up the values for
in this case it can make sense to use an
include column or 2 so that your index
can cover the query and avoid the key
lookup operation
if you start adding 3 or 4 or more
columns as include columns in your
indexes though then that is probably a
warning that you are going a little too
far with include columns in creating
covering indexes
what you are essentially doing is making
another skinned down version of your
table
but what that mean is that when any of
these columns get updated sql server
will also have to update the entries in
the index to keep it up to date
so you are going to incur higher
maintenance cost for your index by doing
this
if you have a query that only needs one
or two columns including columns and a
covering index can provide a nice
additional performance boost just be
careful not to go overboard and include
too many columns
such that you basically now have another
copy of your table
sometimes to improve performance we need
to create numerous indexes on the table
which unknowingly leads to over indexing
in the next video we are going to
discuss about over indexing
you are watching the video module 3
building effective indexes part 9 over
indexing
we have seen how indexes can speed up
our sql statements and reduce the number
of resources it takes for sql server to
run our statements
so you might be tempted to think that we
should create indexes for every column
on every index in our database
even if those columns are rarely used in
any where clauses or join clauses for
our statements
unfortunately this isn't quite the case
while you want to create indexes that
will be used by the sql statements in
your application
you also want to be careful not to over
index your database
and by over index i mean create indexes
that aren't going to be used by any
statements in your or any other
application that are running against
your database
the reason why is that index has a
maintenance cost of them
and if these indexes aren't helping
speed things up in your queries then you
are paying this maintenance cost without
getting any value from this indexes
so let's understand this more
when we create an index sql server
creates a separate physical structure
that contains the data for the index
namely the values of the index keys and
any include columns that are stored in
the tree structure of the index
when any sort of dml operation is
performed on the table sequel server has
to keep all of the indexes on the table
in sync with the data in the table
so this means that when an insert or
delete statement is performed against
the table sql server will also have to
add or remove an entry from all the
indexes on the table
when an update statement is running if
the values of any of the column in the
index are modified then the index has to
be updated as well
all of this has to be happened when the
dms statement executes against the table
so sql server can keep all of the data
in a consistent state
so you want to regard your indexes as
investments
if an index is being used by statement
in your application and is helping
speeding up those statements then the
cost of the index is well worth it
because for most applications the
queries that the index helps speed up
are run far more frequently than any dms
statements against the table
so the index is good investment if
however you have an index that is never
used or is used only rarely
you want to investigate why the index is
not being used and possibly consider
dropping it
so how can you tell this
well sql server contains a number of
views called dynamic management views
that gives you
access to all types of performance
statistics and diagnostics information
within the database engine itself
we will talk much more about these views
in the next module
but among these views is one that gives
us index usage statistics
so we can use a query like the one you
see on the screen to look at the values
in the user c column
and compare it to the user updates
column and as long as we have more seeks
than updates we are in a good shape
otherwise if all we are seeing are
values in the user update column
this indicates we are paying the cost of
the index
but not getting any value out of it
so it may be appropriate to drop the
index
there is one more topic i want to
discuss and that is the index
recommendation that are made by sql
server that we have seen pop-up
throughout the module in management
studio
so we will discuss it in the next video
you are watching the video of module 3
building effective indexes part 10
interpreting sql server index
recommendations
no doubt as you have been watching this
module you have been seen a number of
index recommendations pop-up in
management studio while i have been
demonstrating different concepts
and as you experiment with different
statements that your application runs no
doubt you will see this recommendation
pop up then as well
it is very useful to have these
recommendations from sql server
but i would remind you these are just
suggestions and you should not
automatically create an index because
sql server makes a suggestion to do so
in my opinion sql server can be overly
aggressive with some of its
recommendations
and if you follow each and every
recommendation
you would probably end up with the
database that was over indexed
and therefore had sub optimal
performance when it comes to dml
statements
let's look at an example of this that we
have saw in this module
earlier i executed this query with
selected applicants based on their last
name and state
i already had an index over the last
name first name and state columns
which sql server was able to use for
this query
and you can see
though sql server is giving me a
recommendation to create a second index
over just the last name and state column
it is true that this second index would
result in somewhat better performance
for this particular variation of the
query
however since there is already an index
that sql server is able to use
and use pretty effectively
i would personally pass on creating this
second index
the recommendations that sql servers
give you are based on the individual
query that you are running at the moment
so
sql server will try to optimize an index
for that exact query
but what you really want to do is to
look at the different variations of your
statement and their where clauses and
come up with the set of indexes that
will work across all the different
combinations that you have
this means a couple of variations of the
statement may not be 100 optimized but
again we have to consider the trade-off
around creating multiple extra indexes
versus the cost that we will have to pay
to maintain each of those indexes
but it is to say that you should take
this recommendation just as suggestion
and then it is up to you to combine your
knowledge of your application the data
in the database and the suggestion to
come up with the right set of indexes
for your tables
let's summarize what we have learned and
wrap up this module in the next video
you are watching the video module 3
building effective indexes part 11
module summary
having effective database indexes is
probably the most important factor in
determining the performance of your
application data access layer
so in this module we talked about how
you build effective indexes in your
database we lead off by talking about
what columns you want to be creating
indexes in your database
first among this are any columns that
you are using in the where clauses of
your sql statements
as this is the way that your application
locates the data that it needs
additionally we talk about the need to
index the foreign key columns of your
table to support any join operation we
do
as well as the fact that often our
application will query data across these
foreign key relationships
once we know the columns we need to
create index on we need to make sure
that sql server will actually be able to
use the index we create
the first thing we need to make sure of
that the column in our index are in the
right order as sql server will not be
able to use the index if the first
column in the index is not in the where
clause or join condition of the sql
statement
so that means when we create our indexes
we want to put the column that is most
frequently used as part of our where
criteria at the front of the index
followed by the next most frequently
used column second and so on
we may need to create multiple indexes
to support multiple use cases
but this is where we can use our
knowledge of the application and how our
user query the data to determine the
best column order for our indexes
secondly we want to make sure that our
indexes are selective enough
the idea of an index is that it helps
sql server quickly target a particular
piece of data
so we want indexes that have relatively
few rows per index key
because this really helps sql server to
target on the right data
if we have a column that by itself is
not very selective we can still use it
so long as we have other column in the
index that makes the entire index
selective
and we make sure that the where clause
of our sql statement is also selected
oftentimes we need to use the like
clause in our statements and in doing so
we need to remember that if we use the
wildcard character at the front of the
like value
sql server will not be able to use an
index on the column
if we have the percentage sign somewhere
else in our value sql server will be
able to use the index so long as we make
sure that we have enough information in
the supplied value that it is still
selective
we also saw that if we have a function
in the where clause of a sql statement
this will also cause sql server not to
use an index
and it is this function here on the left
hand side or column side of the where
clause that is the problem
because those computed values are not
stored anywhere so
sql server has to read all the data for
the column and compute these values on
the fly
if we do have a use case in our
application where we need to do
something like this and this example of
using the sound x function to do a
phonetic search might be a good one
then what we can do is to create a
computed column or column on the table
and then create an index over those
computed columns and then the sql
statement we see here would be able to
use the index over those computed
columns values
we then talk about include columns and
covering indexes
a covering index is when sql server
doesn't have to perform a table lookup
to fulfill a query
but instead can get all the data it
needs directly from the index
so
if we already have all but one or two of
the columns we need for a query in an
index we could use an include column to
make that index and covering index
which provides a little bit of an
additional performance boost because sql
server can avoid the additional lookup
operation
the last major topic we discussed was
over indexing
indexes do a great deal to speed up our
statements
especially our queries
but they do require more maintenance
as
sql server has to keep all of the index
on a table up to date whenever a dms
statement is executed against that table
so we want to make sure that we only
create indexes that are really being
used by the statement in our application
so we don't have an adverse impact on
any dml operation that we may have
that's wrap up our discussion of indexes
in the next module i am going to show
you how to find performance bottleneck
in sql server using sql survey built in
dynamic management views
these views contain all sorts of useful
performance information like what
statement is taking the longest to
execute
and if sql server thinks that we are
missing an index that would improve
performance
knowing what information is available in
this views and how to access them can
really speed up the performance
troubleshooting process
so i hope you will join me in the next
module
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server
part 1 module introduction
one of the best feature about sql server
is that internally it is always taking
data about sql statements that are being
run in the database and other events
that are happening
and we can access this data to give us
an overall picture of what is happening
inside of sql server with regards to our
application
for example sql server will give us
statistics on all of the sql statements
that have been executed in our
application database over the last
several hours
including how many times a statement has
been executed
how long the statement took on average
to run
how much cpu would the statements
consumed and how much average io needed
to be performed
with data like this we can quickly
identify what statements in our
applications are running well and which
one we might need to do some performance
tuning on
now you might think that you need some
fancy expensive tools to do all of this
and indeed there are lot of tools out
there on the market that exposes this
information to you in a nice user
interface
however these tools are just looking at
data that is already inside of sql
server and all you have to do is to know
where to look to find this data
and then you can just write queries to
get all of the information that you need
the source of this data is a series of
views in sql server known as a dynamic
management views often referred to as
the dmvs for short if you go to this
page on the microsoft website you can
navigate through all of the different
dmvs that are available
and the data they contain
what we are going to do in this module
is just concentrate on a few use cases
that are the most important to us as
developer and the dmvs that we need to
solve this use cases we are going to
start off in this module by talking
about the permission that you need to
query the dmvs then we are going to talk
about how to use the dmvs to see
information like who is connected to sql
server and how many resources each
session is using
then we are going to talk about how we
can find what sql statements are
currently executing against our server
then we will talk about how to find the
most expensive statements that are
running against our database
next we will talk about how we can query
sql server to see if it has any
recommendation about indexes that might
be missing in our database that we need
to create
and finally we will discuss how we can
find if our current index are being used
and how often
although this gives us a good database
level summary of how our application is
interacting with sql server
and it makes it easy for us to spot any
performance bottlenecks that may exist
one last item i do want to mention is
that all of the queries you are going to
see in this module are located on my
blog
so if you go to the link that you see
here on the screen i will also mention
this link in the description for your
convenience all this query will be there
so you don't need to worry about pausing
the video and trying to type this query
in on your own
so with that let's start by talking
about the permission we need in sql
server in order to access the dmvs and
run the queries that we are going to see
in this module in order to query the
dynamic management views your sql server
user needs to have the view server state
permission granted to it and unless you
are a dba you are unlikely to have this
permission by default
traditionally sql server's dynamic
management views has been thought of as
a tool for the dba because they contain
information not just related to
performance but also about system health
and configuration the view server state
permission gives you access to all of
this information and for some dbs this
creates some security concern
to give away that level of access
it may be possible to get this level of
access in your development and test
environments but it completely depends
on the rules of the company whether this
level of access will be available to you
as a non-dba user in a production
database system
if you are at a company that is not
comfortable granting this access in
production to developers you still have
a couple of options though
first you could have your dba execute
the query
shown in this module and forward those
result to you
the second option is that you could work
with your dba team to create some views
over the top of the sql server dmvs that
only exposes a specific subset of the
dmv data to you which would relax any
security concerns
for this module i am going to assume
that you do have the view server state
permission available to you as i show
you these queries so with that being
said let's start taking a look at some
of the information sql server can
provide to us around connections and
sessions in the database
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server part 2 getting information about
sql server sessions and resource usage
the first query we are going to look at
is a query that uses the dm
exec sessions dmv in sql server to get a
list of all the clients that are
connected to our sql server database
on my laptop i will get some results
from another process that i have running
so let's go ahead and run this query
right now
so we see we get back some information
like the session id and the database
that the session is currently connected
to
we also get a status if this session is
doing anything at the moment either
running or sleeping
and we also get when the session was
initiated
then we get some performance stats about
each session
the cpu time here is in millisecond
memory usage is in 8 kb block and we
also have read write and logical leads
so if we had a session that are
consuming a lot of resources and maybe
slowing everyone else down that are
connected to sql server we did be able
to tell that from this data
next we see that we have some
information about the client process
that owns this session
including the host name the program name
and the host process id
so if we need to know where a session
was coming from this would be enough
information to help us figure that out
now a lot of times what you are going to
see in this program name column is
something like we see here
net sql client data provider
and not the actual name of the program
that's making the connection
for any dotnet program it is this string
that is put in by default
what you can do though is in the
connection string of your program you
can include this property application
name and then the value that you specify
here in the application name property
will be used to populate the program
name in the column in sql server when
you have multiple applications that are
using the same database this can be
really useful because then you can very
easily tell which session is coming from
which application
the result of this query are useful in
two situations one like we said when
there is a session that is consuming a
lot of resources on sql server
second we are also getting a lot of
connectivity information here in terms
of what clients are connected and how
many connection each client is using
so for example if i have 4 servers in
web cluster i would expect to see about
the same number of connections from each
one of those machines if i saw that one
of those web server didn't have any
connection to sql server i would want to
go and check the connection string on
that machine
and also make sure that server was
actually receiving in processing web
request so there is actually quite a bit
that you can tell just by looking at the
session information
now another question you might want to
answer is what sql statement are
currently executing in sql server right
now
so we will look at how to answer that
question in the next video
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server
part 3 finding what sql statements are
currently executing
sometimes we have the need to see what
statements are running right now in sql
server
imagine you have a situation where your
application is running very slowly or
maybe even appears to be unresponsive
and you need to quickly be able to treat
that situation
so you may be trying to figure out if
this is a problem in the application
code
maybe a web service you are calling is
down or maybe you have a query in sql
server that takes very long time
so what you want to be able to do is
look at sql server and quickly figure
out what your app is doing in the
database
and if the problem you are seeing is in
the database tire and so we can answer
this question with a query like we see
on our screen right now
this query seems quite long but we will
walk through it and we will see that
actually it's pretty straightforward
so we will scroll down to where we can
look and see what dmvs this query is
using first
we see that what this query does is it
joined together the dm
exec
sessions and dm ex ec request view so
that we can get what statements are
currently running for each session
then we need to bring in the text of
this statement and we do that with the
dm
exec sql text view and the execution
plan of the statement is brought in with
the dm exec query plan view
what this will allow us to do is that if
we see a statement that we want to know
more about we will be able to just click
on that execution plan in the result set
and bring that execution plan up
so that is pretty useful
also in the dm exec request view there
is a column called blocking session id
and if there is another session that has
a sql statement that is blocking this
sql statement
that column will have a non-zero value
so that is what these three views here
are about
if a sql statement is being blocked by
another session we will get all of the
information on the blocking statement
and blocking session right here in the
same query
looking at the where clause these lines
tells sql server not to return any
statement from our current session
so basically we are not going to get our
dmv query that we are looking back here
in our result set
also we have this line here which is
going to limit the result to the current
database if you want to see all of the
activities on the server you would just
remove this line or command it out
let's jump back up to the top to where
we can see what data we are getting back
we have the session id of the sql server
session
and we also have the sql statement here
these three line here that are labeled
sql statement what these are doing is if
the statement that running is part of a
stored procedure these are getting the
individual sql statement so we can look
at
if we have just a plain old sql
statement then the sql statement field
and the parent statement field which is
down here those are going to be the same
but if we are inside of a stored
procedure we will get the individual
statement here and then parent statement
will be the name of the stored procedure
you can see we also have some
information about the client that is
running the statement and this includes
the host name the program
and the process id of that client
so for example
if an asp.net web app was running a
statement
the process id field here would contain
the process id of the worker process
over on the iis web server
then we have some statistics about the
statement itself
including what time the statement
started
how long it has been running
how much cpu it has consumed and how
much io it has performed
in most situation these numbers are
going to be quite low
because most statements run for a couple
of hundred of milliseconds
if you have a statement though that's
taking a long time you would see that
reflected in these values
and if you can run this query over and
over again you would see these numbers
continue to increase with each
subsequent run
so that it could indicate that the
statement is not just running a long
time but also consuming a lot of
resources
as it's running on the database server
we can see that we are also getting the
execution plan back in the query plan
field
so if we do have a statement running we
can look and see what is doing inside of
the sql server
and then we also have the blocking
session information
but this will only be populated if
indeed our statement is being blocked
so let's go ahead and run this query and
see what we get
so here we see that on my system at the
moment that i run this query we have few
statements coming back
on a real production system you would
probably see more statements in more
variety than what we are seeing here by
just running locally on my laptop
we see all of the fields that we talk
about so if we want the sql it's right
there and then we also see some
statistics
what i want to show you though is if i
move over here to the right we have the
execution plan labeled in this query
plan field
and i can just click on this
so management studio popups the
execution plan that's being used by the
statement and that's pretty useful
because we can see the actual execution
plan that the statement is running
especially we have a performance problem
in a production environment
because this can clue us in about what's
actually happening up on our database
server
it's useful to know what's running right
now
but other times we want to be able to
get a bigger picture view of performance
and what statements are performing well
and which ones aren't
so we will talk about the query that
will do that for us in the next video
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server
part 4 finding the slowest and most
expensive sql statement
one of the most useful thing you can do
with the sql server dms is to have sql
server gives you a list of all the
statements that your application has run
along with the execution statistics for
those statement
if you are looking for some quick bins
for performance in your application this
query is a great place to start
because this immediately tells you what
statements are performing well and what
statements you need to target for
performance tuning
so how does sql server know this
every time sql server processes a
statement it keeps tracks of the
execution plan that it uses
and some execution statistics about the
statement and store this data in an
in-memory structure
inside of sql server
since this data is in memory what data
inside the structure can and does change
as new statements are run and old
statements are cached out
but generally you will have the last
several hours worth of data available in
the dmv that shows you this view
and this is plenty of data to get a
strong pulse about what is happening
with your application
so let's look at this query
this query is based around the dm exec
query stats view and you can see that we
are also pulling in the
text of the sql statement and the
execution plan for the statement
this is handy to pull in the execution
plan because if you do find a poorly
performing statement we can look at the
plan being used and use the skills we
have learned in the last couple of
modules to analyze the plan for the
statement
if we look back up towards the top of
the editor window
we see the data that we are returning
we see that we have the sql text like
before so we know what statements we are
talking about
and then we have a number of stats about
this statement
like the number of times that it's been
executed the average amount of cpu per
execution and the total amount of cpu
across all executions
and we have similar measures for both
logical i o and alph stamp
one thing i do want to point out is that
the total rows column here
this was added in sql server 2008 r2
so if you are still on sql server 2008
you will want to comment this line out
what is useful to do though with this
query is that we can take the result of
the query and we can sort those result
by various parameters
with this query right now at the moment
i am actually sorting by the average
alerts time so that's going to be
statements that taking the longest
however i could also sort this by the
average amount of cpu time per statement
execution or the average amount of io to
find the most resource hungry statements
if you can also be really interested to
sort the results by the number of
execution so you can see what statements
from your applications are getting run
most frequently
if you see a statement that has a very
high number of executions maybe that
statement is being executed inside of a
loop
and you want to rethink how you are
doing that data access or maybe the data
returned by that statement is
essentially static
so you might want to consider if you
could possibly catch that data
so like all the queries that i am
showing you in this module take a moment
and experiment with these queries in
your database
because that's really the best way to
learn how to use this query and what
they can tell you
so let's go ahead and run this query
so this is what your data is going to
look like when it come back
and this is pretty straightforward to
interpret this data
one thing that i want to point out is
our dime based measurements
which are the cpu time and the ellipse
time column this units are in
microseconds
so we move the decimal places over 6
places to the left
we can see that i have got a number of
statements here that are taking over 5
seconds
and it look like those statements are
also are using a lot of cpu
so if this was a real database i did be
pulling the sql out of here
and then i will be scrolling over here
to the right where i can see the
execution plan for the statements to
analyze what is going on
so you can see this query is very useful
because it can help you immediately
pinpoint any statement that are really
slowing down your application so you can
get those fixed
even after i have tuned all of these
statements in my application i still
like to run this query every week or so
just to make sure that nothing has
changed or snug up on me in terms of a
performance issue
next we are going to take a look at how
sql server can give us some
recommendation on if any indexes are
missing in our database
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server
part 5 getting sql servers
recommendation on missing indexes
we have seen in this course that when we
run a sql statement in management studio
if sql server thinks the statement would
benefit from an index it will give us
that recommendation right in management
studio
sql server doesn't just make this
recommendation in management studio
but
anything a sql statement is run these
recommendations are logged to a series
of dmvs known as the missing index dmes
we don't want to automatically create
every index that is recommended
in this series of views
but looking at this result can help us
finding an index that we may have
otherwise overlooked
the query you see on your screen will
join these views together and give us
some statistics about the
recommendations
so let's go ahead and run this query to
see what we get
the first column in the result set is
the table name
and this is the table that the index
recommendation is for
then we have three columns contain
information about what columns a
potential index would be created across
and we see the column names are given to
us in a comma separated list within each
of these columns
mainly you are going to be looking at
the column called equality columns
because most where clauses and join
clauses are based on the equality
relationship
we also see that we have some stats
about why sql server thinks this index
would be a good idea
this two column here user scans and user
seeks
represent the number of times that sql
server could have used this index had
this index exist
so for this top row this means that sql
server could have performed an index
seek operation against this index over
12 000 times had the index existed
we also see the average cost of the
statements that could have used the
index was and this is the cost of the
statements without the index existing
the next column
avg user imp
tells us the percentage that sql server
thinks that this cost would have reduced
if we have had this index
finally the last two columns are some
simple calculations
the first column give us the average
cost saving per statement we would have
by having this index
and the last column give us the total
saving we would have across all
statements that could benefit having
this index
so this last value is useful to sort
these results to get an idea
what the most impactful index to create
might be
now when you run this query and pull
this list up
what you don't want to do is just start
working your way down the list and
creating an index for each row in this
result set
this is because sql server has a
tendency to recommend an index to
optimize every individual statement and
if you did that you would be in a over
index situation
which would slow down all your dml
statements against your table
instead what you want to do is to scan
through the result for each table you
will able to pick out some pattern of
index recommendation across similar
columns
and then you can combine the information
with your knowledge of how your
application works to come up with the
right sets of index for each table
so for example this last 5
recommendations that are in the list are
all about the student table
and by scanning through the columns that
are recommended we see that all of the
recommendation includes the last name
column
so we know that we need to have an index
that start with last name
we also see that first name is used in
three of the recommendation so that is
good choice for the second column in our
index and then maybe we will choose
state as a third column because that's
used two of the recommendation as well
the point is that you want to look at
the different recommendations for a
table and extract out the common columns
such that you are creating the fewest
number of possible indexes on the table
in a lot of cases you will have a number
of similar recommendations that all have
a common subset of columns
so you want to create just one index
that contains those common columns
this way you are creating an index that
can benefit multiple statements rather
than trying to create individual index
for each statement which would be
inefficient
so when you look at the results of this
query keep in mind that these are just
recommendations
and it's up to you to analyze and
combine this recommendation together
into the actual indexes that you are
going to want to create on your tables
now the flip side of missing an index is
having index on table that aren't being
used
so we will look at a dmv query that can
help us finding those situation in the
next video
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance button lag in sql
server part 6 finding indexes that are
not being used
in the last module
we talked about how sql server has to
maintain any index you create on your
tables
by updating an index every time a dml
statement is executed
against the table
so while an index will greatly speed up
a query there is a slight performance
penalty in terms of executing a dms
statements against the table
therefore we want to make sure our
application is using all of the indexes
we have created in our database
because otherwise we are paying the cost
of maintaining an index which is not
being used or
not giving any benefit
and we can do this with a query that
looks like what you are seeing on your
screen
which uses the dm db index usage stats
dmv in conjunction with the sys indexes
system
views i will run this query and then we
can discuss how it works
so we see in the first few columns we
have information like the table name
the index name and the index type
remember that an index type of cluster
really means a table data
as this is how sql server normally
stores the data for a table in a cluster
index structure
what is really of interest to us though
are these statistics that are located
out at the right of the result set
and i am going to expand this column
just a little bit so we can read this a
little bit better
and there we go
so user seeks scan and lookups each
represent the number of times
respectively that the index has been
used of those types of operations since
sql server was last restarted
so for a standard non-cluster index that
we would evaluate
we would be most interested in the value
of user 6
as
this is the number of times that sql
server is using the index as intended by
searching the tree structure of the
index for matching keys
we also see that we have a column named
user updates
and this value reflects the number of
times that sql server has had to update
the index
because of a dml statement being run
against the table
now when you run these statements on
your database you aren't going to see
all zeroes in this columns like i am
but you will see actual values
what you are looking for here is indexes
that have high number of updates and
very low usages
generally meaning a low number of user
seeks operation
this means that we are having to update
the index more often than its being used
so if we find one of these situations we
want to investigate why this is
happening
maybe the index has a wrong column order
or it isn't selective enough
or maybe something has changed in our
application such that we are not
querying a table in the same way that we
are used to
whatever the case you want to understand
the situation and see if you can
possibly modify that index so it can be
used
or if you determine that the index
really doesn't have a purpose then you
want to drop the index so it isn't
slowing down your dms statements
i do want to give you one word of
caution
though sometimes you have an index that
isn't used by your website or other
interactive applications
but it is critical to a night batch
process
in this case you will have only a
handful of usages of the index
because of course a nightly batch
process usually runs just once per night
but you don't want to drop these indexes
because otherwise there will be serious
performance consequences for those batch
processes
so just make sure that when you are
getting ready to drop an index you have
really thought through all of the
processes that may be using the
underlying table
and make sure you have not missed an
important use case like a nightly or
weekly batch process
let's go ahead and wrap up our
discussion of dmvs and this module in
the next video
you are watching the video of module 4
finding performance bottlenecks in sql
server part 7 module summary
in this module we have seen that sql
server collects all types of diagnosis
and performance information and makes it
available to us via its dynamic
management views
by queering these views we can get an
overall picture of what is happening
with our application inside of sql
server
so we can quickly identify problem areas
and address them
we looked at five different queries that
we could use and these queries gave us
information on what client had sessions
connected to sql server
what sql statements are currently
executing
what statements are taking the longest
to run and using the most resources
inside the
sql server
what indexes might be missing in our
database and what the current usage of
our existing indexes is
there are many more queries that could
be written
and of course the queries we have shown
here
would all be modified
really the best way to learn about dmvs
is to try them out on your system
and you will be sure to learn something
about your application data access layer
in the next module we are going to
continue talking a more global view of
how our application interacts with sql
server and demonstrate how you can trace
all the sql statements that your
application sends to sql server
and at the same time collect detailed
performance data about them
so let's start it from the next video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server part 1 module
introduction
in this module we are going to talk
about the ways you can trace all your
data access statements inside of sql
server
and by trace i mean capture each
statement your application run inside of
sql server along with some performance
statistics about that statement
why would we want to do this
well
there are couple of common reasons
one as a developer we might want to know
exactly what a process inside one of our
applications is doing inside of sql
server
maybe we are trying to debug a process
that doesn't seem to be working
correctly or maybe we have taken over
support of an existing application
what tracing allows us to do is to see
the exact sql statements the application
is running with their values and the
order in which they are being run
in so
we can tell exactly what table are being
hit and how they are being used
which is really useful for debugging
second when we use the tracing
capabilities that are built into sql
server we can get detailed performance
information for each statement that is
being executed from our application
in the last module we saw how we can get
aggregate statistics like average cpu
time or average logical reads by
querying sql servers dynamic management
views
as we will see when we trace our data
access in sql server
we will be able to get statement level
statistics for each statement that is
run
so we can really understand in detail
how each statement is performing
so we might use tracing in one of our
development environments to understand
how one of our applications is working
or we might use it in a test environment
during a load test of our application
together
detailed information about what parts of
our data access are performing and which
parts needs to be tuned
and finally we could even use a trace in
our production environment if we wanted
to capture detailed information about
every statement that took over a certain
amount of time let's say 5 second or
accelerate some other performance
threshold
in sql server there are two different
ways which you can trace what is
happening inside of the database
and which one you choose depends on the
version of sql server that you are
running
if you are running sql server 2008 r2 or
earlier
you should use a tool called sql
profiler and this is provided as a
separate gui in the sql server client
tools
if you are running sql server 2012 or
later
or using sql azure then you are going to
use what are known as sql server
extended events to perform your trace
going forward sql server extended events
are going to be standard and in fact the
only way to perform a trace in sql
server
as the sql profiler tool was depreciated
in sql server 2012
you can check out this on microsoft site
with the link shown on screen
but you will still find sql profiler
widely used
so we will cover it
but known that the trend is moving
towards extended events
so if you are on sql server 2012 or
later you want to be investing your time
in learning how to use extended events
and probably skip learning profiler
regardless of which approach you end up
taking
running a trace on sql server requires
some pretty high level permission in the
database
which we will discuss when we
demonstrate each approach
this is because a trace can capture
every sql statements and it value that
are being executed against the database
and clearly there are some security
concern in letting someone do this
if you have sql server installed on your
workstation
you will be able to run a trace for any
local testing that you do against that
local instance
for your development and test
environments if you will be able to run
a trace is going to be vary by company
in production you will almost certainly
not have permission to run a trace by
yourself
and will need to engage someone from
your dba team to help you run a trace
however don't be discouraged by this
quite the opposite
being able to trace all of your
applications sql is a powerful
capability and it is important that you
have a developer be aware of its
capability and what it can do so that
when you need to do it you know that the
capability exists and you can ask for it
so what we are going to do in this
module is guide you through using both
sql profiler and sql server extended
events to take a trace for each method i
will show how to set up a trace
including what events you can log how
you can filter the data you capture and
how you log this data to a file for
later review
i will also discuss what you need to do
in order to analyze this data
when we are finished you will have a
good overview of how to set up a trace
in both tools
and a good idea of what data you can
capture within sql server
this will help you understand what
tracing capabilities exist in sql server
so you know when a trace might be useful
in your application development process
so let's get started by looking at the
sql profiler tool in the next video you
are watching the video module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server
part 2 setting up of sql profiler trace
to run sql profiler you have to go to
your microsoft sql server tools in your
start menu
here you can see on must install
it is labeled sql server profiler 18
and you just click on this icon
you can also start sql server profiler
from sql server management studio
for that
click on tools menu
then the first menu is sql server
profiler
once you click on the sql server
profiler menu
the app will open
and this is what the screen will look
like
you want to go up here to the left upper
corner
and click on the icon that is all the
way on the left to start a new dress
then as we see here we have a login
dialog box pop-up and what we need to do
here is to login to the sql server
instance
where we want to run the sql trace on
also we need to log into sql server as a
user that has the altered trace
permission
otherwise when we click connect here we
are going to get an error
in this case i am just running a trace
on my local sql server instance so i
will have a permission to do this
but as we talked about in the intro of
the module you may or may not have
rights to run a trace against different
sql server
at your company
so i will click connect here and then we
will presented with this dialog box
where we can specify the various options
for the trace that we are going to
perform
so first we will specify a name and then
we don't have to specify an output file
where we want this data to go
but it's a generally a good idea so you
can review the data later
so we are going to check this box to
save to a file
and we will specify a file name here
and then we get this option to specify a
maximum file size
which i am going to set 25 mb
then i also want to make sure that file
rollover is set
so as this files fill up profiler with
roll them over to a new file
now what i want to do is to set the
events i want to capture
and some filter criteria about what to
capture
and i do that on this second tab called
event selection
you can see we already have some default
selected
and from a developer perspective
wanting to trace some sql statements and
get their performance information
these are actually some pretty good
defaults
these names are pretty self-explanatory
but if you mouse over one of them you do
get some additional description down
here in the lower part of the dialog
the rpc completed event will fire when a
stored procedure completes
and the sql batch complete event fires
when individual statements completes
so you want to make sure to have both of
this event checked
so you can capture all the sql from your
application
this is important even if you are not
using stored procedure explicitly
because the way that some of the
database drivers work
they actually in some cases will wrap
your sql inside of the sp execute sql
build in procedure
so you just want to make sure that both
of these boxes are checked also you want
to make sure to check the box labeled
text data here on rpc completed
because this is what is going to let us
see the sql that's been executed as part
of that event
if you can see that we have a number of
other parameters here like cpu and
logical reads and i suggest you to leave
all of this checked so you get this
performance information
now there are many other events that you
can capture and to see all of these
events you check this box here named
show all events
as you can see this list is quite
extensive
though most of the items in this list
are of more interest to dbs than to us
as developers
i am not going to go through each and
every one of these obviously but there
is one that i want to point out and that
is in the error and warnings section and
the event name is user error messages if
you have a sequel statement in your
application that throws an error when it
runs
that error will be captured by this
event
so this can be useful debugging tool if
that error isn't otherwise getting
bubbled up to your application logs
this event will also log some
informational messages that sql server
generates but for our purposes we can
disregard those informational messages
because what we are really interested in
for this event is the ability to capture
errors from our sql statements
i am going to uncheck the show all
events check box and you see this gets
up back to just the event that we are
going to capture
and now we want to talk about this other
button here column filters
the way we have things right now we are
going to capture every login logout and
sql statements that executed across the
entire sql server instance
if you are running a trace against your
local install of sql server
that will probably work fine because you
are probably the only user but on a busy
server you are going to capture a lot of
events that you don't care about
this not only makes it harder to sort
through all of the data and find what is
important to you
but it can also have a negative impact
on the performance of sql server because
you are capturing so many events
so we want to filter the data so that we
just capturing the data that's of
interest to us
one of the things you probably want to
do is to limit the data you collect to
just your application
you can do this using the application
name filter or by the login name filter
assuming that your application uses a
unique login for sql server
if you go to the application name root
remember you need to set this
application name in the connection
string your application uses
in dotnet this is done by including the
application name parameter in the
connection string and something similar
can be done in other languages as well
you can also limit your trace to
statements that takes a longer time or
use a lot of resources with columns like
duration
cpu or writes
to set one of these just click on it and
then
go over here to the criteria you want to
set
and in this case i want queries that
takes longer than 5 seconds
so that's 5000 milliseconds
and set the value
and now this trace would capture just
this long running queries
if you want to get rid of this criteria
which i do for the demo
that i am going to run in just a second
here then you just double click on the
values so that you can edit the values
and delete it
and now that criteria will not be used
anymore
so now we have our trace setup and in
the next video we will continue with
this and go ahead and run this trace and
collect some data you are watching the
video module 5 capturing what your
application is doing inside sql server
part 3 running a sequel profile address
so we got our sql profiler trace setup
in the last segment
and now all we have to do to run the
trace is to click this button here
that says run
now in the background you should know i
do have a program running
that's generating some synthetic load
against my sql server instance
so we will be able to see something when
we actually run this trace
so i will go ahead and click this button
and there we go
we see this window pop-up and we can see
the events that are being captured by
the trace in this window
now running the trace interactively like
this is fine if you are on a local
machine like i am
or otherwise maybe a dev server that has
a very very light load on it
but you don't want to run a trace
interactively like i am doing against a
busy server because
otherwise you could really cause some
performance degradation on that server
there is a way to convert our setup here
to run what is called a server side
trace
that runs just up on the server itself
and captures its data to a file
and that's more efficient and i will
show you how to do that in just a moment
but for now
know that this interactive mode is
something that you only want to be doing
locally
or maybe you do it for just a very brief
instance of time on a server to make
sure you are capturing the right data
and then you turn it off
that way you can avoid any performance
impact
i am going to actually go ahead and stop
this trace
because i think we have captured enough
data to review in the time that i have
been talking
and so to stop the trace we just hit
this stop button here
in the main pane
we see the event that are captured by
the stress in the order
they occurred
if i click one of these i will see the
text of the command down here in the
lower pane with the values that were
submitting for this query
i can also see up here in the main grid
some of the performance stats about this
statement
like cpu reads rights and duration
so what i can do is i can scroll through
here and i can look for statements that
were the most expensive ones
and then inspect the sql for that
statement
and any parameters that were used in
that statement
what is lacking about this user
interface is that there is no way to
sort or filter the data once it's been
taken
so you can see i can go up here and
click on the column header and nothing
happens
i am not getting the data to sort here
so if you want to be able to slice and
dice this data
what you are going to do is to save this
data to a database table
and then you can query it with just some
normal sql like any other table
so to do this you are going to go up
here to the file menu and then down to
save as
and then select trace table
this will prompt you for a database
login and what you are going to want is
a place and a login that profiler is
going to be able to create a table to
store this trace data in if that table
doesn't already exist and so what i have
done on my machine here is i have
created a separate trace database called
trace data on my local sql server
instance
and that's where i am going to put this
data
so i will go ahead and login
and then i am going to find trace data
in this list for my databases i will
leave the schema as dbo and finally i am
going to give this table a name
and now i will click ok
and so that's going to do is to take
this data and create that table and
insert all of the data into the table
and so now if i pop up over to
management studio i can go and i can
find the database
and i will open the tables and there is
our table
and i will just right click so that i
can grab the first thousand rows
and there those rows are
so obviously i could write sql queries
against this table like any other table
and i could filter and sort this data
however i wanted to
now that i have it in a table
we mentioned that you could also run a
trace as a server-side trace which is
more efficient and therefore more
appropriate if we are trying to trace
access in a server environment rather
than on our local machine
so let's see how to do that in the next
video
you are watching the video module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server part 4 running a trace
as a server-side trace
when you use sql profiler to trace your
sql statements what you really want to
do is to run your trace as a server-side
trace rather than a interactive mode
because a server-side trace will consume
fewer resources in sql server
so what we do is use the sql profiler
tool to setup the trace
meaning we select the events we want and
add in any filters and then we can
instruct profiler to give us a sql file
of the commands
that need to be run in order to run this
trace on the server side
so let's see how to do this
i have the same trace here that we have
been using throughout
and we have this all set up
and then all we need to do is go up here
to file
export and script trace definition
then we will choose from sql server 2005
to 2019
and we are just going to save the sql
file somewhere on our local machine
so now what we need to do is we need to
open that sql file in management studio
and i will jump over to management
studio and i actually have a version of
this file that i saved earlier
already opened up here in the window
that we can see
we see that all the sql file is a series
of commands that we are going to run on
sql server
the only thing that we need to do is to
put in a file name of where the data is
going to be logged to
and we see that we need to do that right
here and there is nice long command
telling us exactly what we need to do
the file path is going to be the path
that is going to be up on a sql server
so that need to be a directory that
exists on a machine that hosting sql
server
in my case i am running sql server
locally so the client and server are one
of the same
but just remember that part is up on the
server
so i will go ahead and set this
and then we will look through the rest
of the file here just to see what else
is in here
and what all these commands do is they
set up the events that we want to
capture
and any filters
so sql profiler has generated all of the
correct
sp trace
set event commands for us so we don't
have to look up all of these different
codes and ids
so all we have to do to start the trace
now is to run this script
again you will need to be logged in as a
user with the altered trace permission
in order to run this trace
otherwise you are going to get an error
the user i am logged in as does have
this permission
so i am going to go ahead and get this
trace started
and so now this trace will be running up
on the server and collecting data
and logging that data to the output file
that we specified
one important thing to note here is the
id number for the stress
that you get back down here in the
result pane
because this is what we are going to
need to stop the trace once we have
captured all of the data that we need
so let's talk next about how we manage
this trace so first of all you might
want a status on what traces are running
on sql server
or maybe you forgot that number of the
trace that we have just started
so let's see how we can find that
information out
i will go over here to this other window
where i have a couple of queries
and what you want to do is you want to
query the system function fn trace get
info
and by passing a 0 to this function
you will get back information on all
traces that currently exist in sql
server
so i am going to go ahead and run this
statement
and you see we get this information back
but this isn't a very user friendly
format
trace number one is the system default
trace that's always running
and then we see the information we have
on your trace
and we can convert it out our trace id
the file and status information from
this
but it's not very user friendly so if we
run this second query here
this will give us a little bit
friendlier view of the data so let's go
ahead and run that
and you see
that's the same information
it is just in a little bit better format
for us to consume
so now we have our trace that's been
running for a while
we have collected the information that
we need
and we want to stop this trace
and so how do we do that
well
what we do is we run a stored procedure
name sp trace set status
and i have the various use cases of that
stored procedure over in this third
window
so as you can see here you pass in your
trace id and a value of 0 if you want to
stop the trace
if after some time you want to restart
the trace you would pass in the trace id
and a value of 1 to restart that trace
so then after you have stopped the trace
if you want to remove the definition of
the trace from sql server
you would call this procedure again with
the value of 2
and what that does is it just remove the
definition of the trace in sql server
it doesn't go out and delete any trace
file that was generated whenever sql
server restarts all these
definitions get removed
this is just a way that we can clean up
things
when we are finished and keep our sql
server tidy so i am going to go ahead
and i am going to stop this trace
and so at this point we have covered
what you need to know about how to run a
server side trace
now once one of these traces has been
taken either by you or maybe somebody on
your dba team
and you have this dot trc file
of the trace data
how do you view the data that's in this
file that's pretty easy
you just open them up in sql profiler so
i am going to go back
to sql profiler and i will select file
open and then trace file
and then i just find the trace file i
want to open
i select and say open in the dialog box
and now that file will open up in
profiler
from here you can review the file in
profiler or use profiler to load the
data into a table in sql server whatever
meets your needs
this wraps up our discussion of sql
profiler so now we are going to move on
and talk about sql server extended
events
which for our purpose do much the same
thing
but is really the preferred tool on new
versions of sql server for taking traces
like this
and also gives us the capability to
trace sql statements on sql azure also
so we will take a look at extended
events in the next video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server
part 5 introduction to using extended
events for sql tracing
if you are using sql server 2012 or
later or using sql azure then extended
events is the way to go in terms of
tracing what sql is running inside of
your database
sql server extended events use the event
tracing for windows or etw framework to
trace data and this framework is newer
and more efficient in terms of server
resources than the older tracing
framework
using sql profiler
extended events also gives you access to
many more events within sql server that
can be traced and logged and many more
options in terms of filtering those
events down to only the ones that you
want
so you want to make sure that you are
familiar with using extended events for
tracing
because this is the direction that
microsoft has chosen
and will be the only option available on
future version of sql server to run an
extended event trace the user running
the trace is going to need some
permission in order to setup and start
the trace
extended events was actually first
introduced in sql server 2008 r2
and if you are on sql server 2008 r2
then your user will need the control
server permission granted to it
on sql server 2012 or later you will
need the alter any event session
permission in order to define and run an
extended event trace
so this is a much more targeted
permission
however having only alter any event
session will only allow the user to
create an extended event trace through
sql
if you want to be able to use the gui
within sql server management studio in
order to define your extended events
capture session
as we are going to do here you also need
the view server state permission for
your user
if you will probably have this
permission on your local instance of sql
server that's running on your
workstation and it may be possible to
get these access rights in your dev and
potentially your test environments
in production at a lot of companies you
will probably be asking your dba group
to define and run these stresses for you
because of security concerns around
production data in servers
but again these tools can be very useful
in your development and application
support process
so we will introduce these tools here so
you are familiar with what capabilities
exist and you are aware of all the tools
that can help you in diagnosting and
solving problems within sql server
in terms of setting up extended event
session to capture events for the
on-premises version of sql server and
for sql azure about 90 percent of the
steps that you need to perform are
common between the two platforms
there are some small differences though
so what i am going to do over the next
few clips
show you how you would set up extended
events to trace your sql on an
on-premises version of sql server
so let's jump in and create new extended
event session to capture some of the sql
inside of sql server in the next video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server
part 6 setting up an extended event
trace
session to set up an extended event
session we use sql server management
studio
what you want to do is in your object
explorer go down and open up the
management folder
then you will see extended events under
it
so expand that
and finally expand sessions
and you will see the existing extended
event trace sessions defined on your sql
server
to define a new session right click on
the session folder and you see you have
two choices here
new session wizard and new session
and i suggest you select the second
choice new session because this is
pretty straight forward to do and there
is not really a need for a wizard
once we do that we will get this window
to pop up and if we look on the left we
have this four pages of configuration
that we will go through to define this
capture session
so we will start out here on this
general page
first we want to give our session a name
and it is good to make this name
descriptive because this is what's going
to show up in the list of management
studio and it will help identify this
configuration in the future
so i will put in a name and then we have
this drop down of template we can choose
from
and we can see those template and in
this case i am going to choose the one
named query batch tracking
once you select a template you will see
that sql server does gives us a good
description of each one of this template
all these templates do is pre-select
some of the events that we can choose
from on the next page
so they make setting up your trace a
little bit faster for us as developers
this query batch tracking is a really
good starting point and then if we wish
we can add more events on the next page
finally on this screen we have some
options that we can start the trace at
server startup or as soon as we create
this trace
and i am going to leave each one of
these boxes unchecked as we will just
start our session manually when we are
ready to
the next phase that we want to look at
is the event page so i will click on
that and on this page the events that
are currently selected to be captured
are over here on the right in this list
and then
this main section in the middle of the
page is where we can search for and
select any other events of interest
you can search for event with the event
search box so i am actually going to do
that for an event
and we see the list is now filtered by
my search criteria i am going to click
on this event query post compilation
show plan
and when i do notice that these two
controls on the bottom populated given
me a description of what this event is
and the data fields that this event will
capture
for this particular event if i scroll
through the description i see that sql
server is warning me that collecting
this event can be very expensive
so if i do choose to turn this event on
i want to be mindful of that and only
collect data for a brief period of time
as not to impact the rest of my sql
server
so that's where the description field
can be really useful because sql server
lets us know if we are collecting a high
resource usage event
if we did want to add this or any other
event to be collected as part of this
trace session we just use these two
buttons here to manage what events were
selected
once we have the list of events then we
have to capture
we can configure what data we want
collected for each of these events
and to do that
we click on this configuration button
that is right here
that button take us to this screen where
we have our selected events on the left
side now and the configuration for each
event is over here on the right
in terms of the data that you collect
for each event that is divided into two
sections
fields that are globally available to
all events which is on this first tab
here
and event specific fields which are out
here on the third tab
so for the rpc complete events we see we
are always going to collect performance
data like the amount of cpu time
duration and logical reads
and that is good because those are
fields of interest to us
and also on the rpc completed event you
just wanted to make sure that the
statement field is checked
because this will allow you to see first
of all the statement and also the
parameter that were passed either to the
stored procedure or the parameterized
query
over on the global field tab there is
one field you want to make sure and
select and that is the sql text field
the reason why you want to make sure
this field is selected is because this
field gives you just the sql text of the
sql statement without the parameter
values
and we will see in a moment that allow
us to group all of the various
executions of a particular statement
together when we start analyzing our
data
so you want to make sure that the sql
text field is selected
and we want to do this both for the rpc
completed event and then also for the
sql batch completed event
and then you can just look through the
list of the rest of the global fields
and see if there are any that make sense
for the trace that you are putting
together
for example you might want to capture
fields like client host name or username
to know what application ran a
particular statement
the last bit of configuration to do on
this screen is to configure the filters
for the event and we want to do this so
we can focus on the data that we are
really interested in
and just collected the data
otherwise we are going to have a lot of
extra data that we are going to have to
sort through and by focusing in on just
the data we are interested in
we can lighten the footprint of any
additional load that we are putting on
sql server
to do this we use the filter tab and
again we are going to need to do this
for each event type that we are
capturing we see that we already have a
couple of default filters in here
and what this filter will do is keep our
session from capturing any internal
system activity run internally by sql
server
since that activity is probably not of
interest to us what we do want to do
though is to limit our session to only
capture data from our application
so there are a couple of ways that we
can do that
you just click here to add a clause and
now i will click on this middle box and
you see all of the criteria that i can
filter by
so if i am on a shared sql server box
that has many many databases i could
come down here to sql server
database name and now i will enter the
value of students in the value field and
i will only capture this event sql batch
completed in the students database
so that will effectively limit me to
only sql statements that are run in the
database
there are many criterias in this list as
you see
so you could only capture statements
that took a certain amount of time or
longer or statements that took a certain
amount of cpu and this could be useful
if you are trying to identify what the
real long running statement in your
application were
you could also put a filter on the sql
text field and then there is like
operator available
so
you could use this to capture all of the
statements then run against a certain
table in your database
i will set up the filter for the other
two event types offline so we can move
on to the last item of configuration we
are going to do
and that is where we are going to store
the data that we capture as part of this
extended event session trace
we configure that on the data storage
page so i will click over there and you
can see by default the storage is of
type ring buffer and what this is as in
memory data structure that acts like a
queue
so in this case you see we will keep
just the last 1000 items
we could use this but what you probably
really want to do is to process this
data you capture to a file
so let's do that
so i will remove this ring buffer by
clicking on the remove button
now i will click add
and i will choose a type and what i want
is an event file
and now i will go down here and i will
select the name and location for a file
and now i am going to say i want a max
file of 250 mb for my file
and now this data will be captured in
the file which is going to be more
useful for us
the last page of configuration is the
advanced page
but we will be in a good shape just to
accept the defaults there
now to create this extended event
session that i have it all configured
all i need to do is to hit ok button
and this session will be created
so in the next video what we are going
to do is we are going to run this
session and we are going to capture some
data on our sql server
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server
part 7
running and configuring the display
settings for an extended event trace
now that we have our trace defined
we just right click on the extended
event session and say start session
and so now this trace session is running
and collecting data to the file that we
set up for the session to log data to
if we want to stop taking data i just
right click again and i would say stop
session
but i am not going to do that just yet
we can see here on our menu that we can
also have another option watch live data
that we can use while the session is
running and we can use this to peek at
any data that the session is capturing
so if we click on this this is going to
bring up this window and now as the
session captures data in real time those
events are going to get displayed in
this window
we are still capturing and logging all
of these events to a file we set up
this just gives us a live view of things
up here in the top part of the window we
see a list of the captured events and if
we click on one of these then we get the
details of that event down here in the
bottom part of the window
now having to click on each and every
event to inspect its results and to find
the data you are looking for in not real
user friendly
and you are going to quickly tire off
clicking through each one of these
events trying to find what you are
looking for
so lets look next at how we can adjust
this view of our data into something
that is more useful
so let's see how we can make our view of
the data a little bit more useful here
we can add columns to the upper part of
this view and turn it into more of a
data grid view in a couple of ways
first if we have an event selected we
can come down here to the data of the
event and just right click on an item
and select show column in table
and then as we see that column now shows
up in our table above
the other thing we can do is right click
on the table header and say choose
columns
and now we get this dialog where we can
choose the columns that we want to see
and the order that we want to see them
in
so i am going to choose a few columns
here
and i will change this order up a little
bit
and now when i click ok we can see that
i have more of a grid view here in the
top part of the pin
and that makes things a lot more useful
if you want to turn off this bottom part
you just go up here and you click on the
button here
and that will toggle the bottom part of
the display on and off
and then once you have a column setup
that you like
what you want to do is you want to save
that setup so you can pull it up again
anytime you are viewing extended events
either a file of extended events or when
you are capturing live events
so to do that you come up here to
display settings and click save as
and we will choose a file name
and now i will click save
and so now when i go back into
management studio and i want to bring up
this view up all i have to do is go up
here to the display settings
say open recent and there is our
configuration file
and we would just click on this
so let's move into analyzing some of the
data that we have captured in the next
video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server part 8 analyzing
extended event trace data
when an extended event session produces
an output file the file produced is an
xel file
and you can open this file right in the
management studio so you just go to the
file
open
file again and then just find the xcl
file on your hard drive that you want to
open and click open and so there we go
we can view our data now
i am also going to get my column
definitions
so i am going to go up and i am going to
do that real quick and now
we have got a better view of our data if
you watch the clips on sql profiler or
you view sql profiler you know that
profiler was pretty limited in terms of
what we could do with the data
but for this extended event files we
actually can do quite a bit in
management studio with this data
first of all i can sort the data just by
clicking on the column header
i can also filter the data right here in
the ui by clicking on the filter button
that's going to bring up this dialog
where we can add filter clauses
so you just click to add a clause and
then you can select the criteria the
operator and the values
if i use the arrow key here to cycle
through some of these values you can see
all the fields that we are collecting
for this event we can now filter on
so i am going to select cpu time as a
filter then i can select greater than
equal to and finally i give this filter
a value of 2 lakhs
because this value is in microseconds so
that will be 2 seconds so this will now
show us in the ui all the statements
that took two seconds or more of cpu
time
so filter like this can be very useful
in order to narrow down the data set and
look at just what you need
in addition to a filter on something
like duration or cpu time we could also
create a filter that was only for a
certain time frame statements from a
certain host or a filter that would look
for a certain table name in the
statement text for our event
so we could see just the statement that
run against a single table
so this is pretty useful what we can do
with filtering right here in management
studio now
and we don't have to go through the
extra step of exporting our data and
getting it into excel or something like
that we can do all of that right here
in addition if we do filter the data
down and we want to share just that
filter subset of data with some of our
colleagues
we can go up here
to the extended event menu item then
down to export to
and you can see that we can export this
filter view of the data to a separate
xcl file
a table in sql server or a csv file
so that's really useful when you just
want to share a subset of data with
someone to analyze
one of the other features that
management studio gives us is that
rather than viewing just a list of raw
events like we are now
we actually can group our events
together and generate aggregate
statistics on them
so let's do that first i am going to
aggregate my data together
and i am going to do that by the sql
text of this statement
which is this column sql text
remember this was the global field for
our events that we made sure to capture
when we set up our trace and we did that
because this field contains just the sql
of the statement or the stored procedure
name and not the parameters
so now that we can group our statements
by that sql
so we see that view of the data here and
this basically tells us how many times
of sql statement or a stored procedure
executed while we are running our trace
if we want to see the individual
statement we just click on the little
plus sign
and then we see the individual
statements under that grouping
we can even sort these statements within
the group by double clicking the column
headers
so of course one of the things you want
to look here is if you have a statement
that's being executed thousands of times
more than any other statements and then
ask yourself what that is
for example maybe a statement is being
executed inside of a loop
so your application is going to the
database over and over and again
and that could be an indication that you
want to take a look at that piece of
code and refactor it
the next thing that we can do is we can
get some aggregate statistics for each
of this statement
and we do that by clicking on the
aggregation button
and now for all of these other fields
that we are displaying we see we can get
some aggregate statistics like average
or sum so for this example i am going to
sum up the cpu and the duration
and i am going to click ok
and now i see i have the summary
statistics displayed along with the
statements so what this allows you to do
is to run a trace which is going to
capture data about a specific process
and then you could filter down just to
that data either at capture time or
after the fact in this video
using the filter button as we just saw
and then for that process that you have
the data for you could figure out not
only which statements had the highest
average cpu usage or the highest
duration which would indicate the
longest average weight but you can also
see that for all the statements that
were running by this process or in this
window of time that you have captured
which statement has the most total cpu
or resulted in the most total duration
that the application was waiting so you
can really zero in on what a process is
doing
and where the performance bottlenecks
are in that process in terms of the data
access
so we have seen how to use extended
events to capture address with the
on-premises version of sql server taking
the trace in azure is very similar there
are just a few differences so we will
cover those in the next video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server
part 9 using extended events in sql
azure
if you are using sql azure you can still
capture what your application is doing
inside of sql azure with extended events
but there are couple of small
differences that you need to account for
first of all you are going to want a
version of sql server management studio
that fully supports sql azure
what this means is that you want to get
the latest version of management studio
and use that to set up your extended
event sessions
earlier versions of management studio
would allow you to connect to a sql
azure database and run queries
but if you try to create an extended
event session you would get an error
with the latest version of management
studio though the ability is setup and
extended event session has been extended
to sql azure database as well
so you will be able to use the same user
interface that we have seen over the
last few clips to setup your event
capture session in sql azure
the second thing you need to do is to
set up a storage location of where you
can write your extended event trace
files to
with sql azure being a platform as a
service offering you don't have a
traditional file system available where
you can write files to
but what you can do is to write your
files to azure storage
and this article on microsoft.com tells
you exactly how to do that
if you read through this article you
will see that there are two steps
step one is that you run a powershell
script to create azure storage container
and this part also create the storage
access policy that will be used to allow
your sql azure instance to be able to
write to that container
when you run this powershell script you
will get an output like i am showing
here
and it is this information that you will
need to feed into the second step of the
process
step 2
evolves running some transact sql in
your sql azure database
if you look at the tsql on the
microsoft.com page as i am here you see
that the sql creates a sample data at
the top of the script and then a sample
trace at the bottom
what is really important though is step
number two because this is what gives
sql azure the credential it needs to
write to the storage location
so what is happening here is that you
are creating some azure storage
putting a security policy on that
storage and then giving the credential
needed to write to that storage to your
sql azure instance
the script covered the details of the
exact command to do this but
big picture that's what's going on
once you have the storage setup now we
can go into management studio and define
an extended event session
when you are looking at an azure
database you will see that the extended
event is under the database itself not
out under a management folder like in
the on premises version
but otherwise we just right click on the
sessions folder and say new session just
like we did before
the selection of the events to capture
what fields you want to capture in those
events and the setup of any filter is
going to be like before
the only real difference is that when we
get the data storage tab
you are going to put the url of your
azure storage container in the storage
url field with the file name
and now this is where your extended
event file is going to be created
so really the process of creating a
trace using extended events on sql azure
is very similar to the on-premises
version of sql server
just make sure that you have the latest
version of management studio and get a
storage location setup
and then you will be able to capture
what your application is doing inside of
a azure database
just like you would be able to do with
the on-premises version of sql server
let's go ahead and wrap up this module
in the next video
you are watching the video of module 5
capturing what your application is doing
inside sql server part 10 module summary
there are many circumstances where we
would like to be able to tell exactly
what our application are doing inside of
sql server and by making use of the
tracing capabilities built into sql
server we can do that
this can really gives us a lot of
insight into what our application is
doing because we can capture the exact
sequence that our sql is being executed
in
so this is really useful for debugging
we can also get detailed statistics on
the execution of each statement that is
run so we can quickly identify which
statements are using the most resources
or taking the longest
finally we get a good idea of how often
our application is running different
statements against sql server and
sometimes simply knowing how often a
statement is run tells you something
important about how your application is
executing
or maybe that there's an opportunity to
combine multiple sql statements into
single statement
if we are on sql server 2008 r2 or
earlier we will use the sql profiler
tool to set up this trace
and then most likely we will export the
definition to a trace definition in sql
so we can run the trace up on the server
since that consume fewer resources for
sql server 2012 and beyond
and for sql azure we will use sql server
extended events
and we can create an extended event
session right in management studio in
both cases we are going to select the
types of events that we want to capture
there are a wide variety of events that
you can capture in the database
but for us developers usually we are
interested in tracing our sql so the sql
batch complete and rpc complete events
are usually the starting point of us
this means that every time our
application runs a sql statement or
stored procedure we will be able to
capture the text of what was run any
parameter used for the execution and
some detailed performance information
like how long the statement took
the number of rows written the amount of
cpu and how many reads the statement
performed we could also supplement these
events with other events of interest to
us for example we see here events around
the start and completion of individual
sql statements and around transactions
finally we will set up some appropriate
filters so we can capture only the data
that we are interested in
we might filter by the database name or
sql server user to look at just the
activity from our application
but we might even filters by the text in
the sql statement just to identify
statements that are running against a
certain table
having good filters like this means
there is less data to sort through
and it also helps limit the load that we
are putting on sql server
once we run our trace we will usually
end up with an output file of all the
events in it that we captured and we can
analyze
if you are using sql profiler you can
just scan through that file or you can
export that data into a table in sql
server
to do detailed analysis
if the output is from an extended event
session we saw that you could do a lot
of your analysis right in management
studio itself
what all of this gives us is the
capability to see step by step what our
application is doing inside of sql
server
so this really helps us understand what
our data access layer is doing
and where we can mix improvements in the
next video we are going to see our last
module of this course that is how we can
apply common performance practices
so let's get start next
you are watching the video of module 6
applying common performance practices
part 1
module introduction
in the other modules of this course we
have concentrated on what is happening
inside of sql server
in this module our focus is a little bit
different
in that we are going to go through some
common performance practices that you
want to apply in your application code
first we will talk about why you want to
make sure to use parameterize sql
when you write your data access code
then we will talk about if it really is
faster to use stored procedures instead
of including your sql directly inside of
your application
next we will talk about commit frequency
and how that can affect the performance
of your data access layer
then we will talk a little bit about
object relational mappers or orms
first we will talk about how using an
orm can make what is happening inside of
sql server a little less visible
and what you can do about it
and finally we will wrap up by talking
about the n plus 1 select problem which
is commonly encountered performance
problem when using orms but fortunately
is easy to resolve
so let's get started by talking about
why it is important to parameterize the
sql in your application
you are watching the video of module 6
applying common performance practices
part 2
use parameterize sql
one practice you want to make sure to
adopt to use parameterized sql
statements in your data access layer
what do you mean by this
consider the sql statement you see on
your screen
the statement is using simple string
concatenation to dynamically build the
sql statement to be run against the
database
what this means is that every time this
data access method is called with
different values a different sql string
is going to be generated and then sent
to sql server to be executed contrast
that without data access method that is
using parameters like the one you see
now on your screen
these two values with the address sign
in your statement signify sql parameters
to sql server and then down here we
attach the values that we want to use
for those parameters when we submit the
statement to the database
so every time this method is run the
same sql is sent to the sql server
and it's just the parameter values that
are attached outside of the sql tags
that will vary
in sql server we will then be able to
substitute those parameters in up on the
server itself there are big two
advantages to this approach of using
parameters first
this helps prevent sql injection attacks
because any value passed in this way are
automatically escaped by the
database so it doesn't matter if a
malicious user has included
some code characters or other special
characters in here to try and do
something inferior
those characters are going to be
automatically escaped in our statement
and that goes a long way into feeding
sql injection attacks like this
the automatic escaping of these strings
also means that you don't have to do
anything special in your code
when a user wants to legitimately
include a single code character in the
value they are entering
like when they are typing the name o
corner or
orale
secondly using a parameterized sql
statement like this will also perform
faster and use fewer resources on sql
server
why is this
remember that every time a sql statement
is sent to sql server sql server has to
determine an execution plan of how to
execute that statement
what actually happens is that sql server
looks in an area of memory known as the
plan cache
to see if it has already executed the
same statement before
and therefore already has an execution
plan that can be used
if yes then sql server can just use this
cache execution plan
if not sql server will have to do
additional work to come up with an
execution plan either through a process
known as a simple parameterization or
through generating a complete new
execution plan
if you are using parameterized sql
statements then once that statement is
run the first time every subsequent
execution of that statement is going to
be able to use the same cached execution
plan
even when different values are included
with a new statement execution
if you are dynamically generating your
sql statements like we saw in the string
concatenation example
the actual sql is different each time so
sql server has to perform this
additional work to get an execution plan
each time
and that additional work will slow down
your application
but maybe more importantly make it less
scalable
the code that you saw earlier in this
clip was part of the simple test
application that i wrote that run the
same sql statement several thousand
times with different values
and you see the result of the test on
your screen
the test took 8.5 seconds of elapsed
time to run almost 7 seconds of cpu time
and we use 79 mb
up in sql to store all those different
execution plans
using parameterized sql statements all
of those same sql statement executed in
under 1 second
and we used almost no cpu time on the
database server since we are using the
same plan over and over again
and as you can see we just use 104 kb of
memory
in the database to cache our execution
plan
so we see that using parameterize sql
not just makes our statement execute
faster but also consumes significant
fewer resources on our database server
and this is a big deal because most
database servers are pretty busy
supporting many many concurrent users so
being efficient about resource
consumption is important
if you are using an orm like entity
framework entity framework core or
hibernate these tools should already be
parameterize your sql for you
but if you are writing your data access
layer using something like ado.net or
jdbc or even using a micro orm
where you are still writing the sql
statements directly
make sure that you are parameterizing
your sql statements
this will provide a performance boost
for your application as well as help to
keep you safe from sql injection attacks
after watching this video you might ask
that are store procedure faster than sql
in application code
so we are going to see that in the next
video
you are watching the video module 6
applying common performance practices
part 3
r stored procedures faster than sql in
application code
if you are being doing database
development for any period of time
you have probably heard someone say that
you should use stored procedure for your
data access layer because stored
procedures offers better performance
than having the sql in your application
code
this is one of those statements that's
been around a long time and it is
partially correct however these
statements alone does not tells the full
story so let's explain what is going on
here
in the last section we compared the
performance of dynamically generated sql
statements to that of parameterize sql
and we saw that parameterized sql was
not just faster but also used less cpu
and memory on the database server
the main reason for this is that when
using dynamic sql sql server has to do
additional work to parse each unique sql
statement and come up with an execution
plan
whereas in the parameterized sql case we
don't need to parse the sql text each
time
and can use the same plan over and over
again
when people say using stored procedure
offers a performance advantage what they
are referring to is that using stored
procedure will outperform dynamically
generated sql
from a performance standpoint stored
procedure are very similar to
parameterized sql statements
you pass in some values to a stored
procedure these are attached to a
statement or statements within the
stored procedure that needed them but
effectively sql server has already
passed the procedure and has an
execution plan
so you are getting the same benefit as
in the parameter sql case
when you compare the performance of
using stored procedure to using
parameterized sql statements the
performance is essentially the same
there is effectively no difference
between the two
now this doesn't mean that there aren't
good reasons to use stored procedures
there are
especially when it comes to security and
restricting excess of data
but from a performance point of view
parameterized sql statements and stored
procedure perform about the same
so the next time you hear the statement
that stored procedures offer better
performance you will understand this
statement comes with a qualifier
stored procedures do perform better than
dynamic sql but as we see in the last
clip we don't want to be writing dynamic
sql anyway
otherwise stored procession and
parameter sequence statements offer the
same benefits in terms of performance
so as long as you choose one of these
strategies you will be fine from a
performance perspective
in the next video we are going to take a
look at commit behavior and how this can
affect the performance of your data
access code
you are watching the video of module 6
applying common performance practices
part 4 commit behavior and performance
when you run an insert update or delete
statement from your application against
sql server an implicit commit is issued
for each statement
because by default the sql server driver
is set with it auto commit behavior
turned on
this is true not just for the dotnet
data provider but also for jdbc oledb
and odbc as well
so consider the code sample that you see
on your screen
what i am doing is adding all of the
courses a student wants to enroll in for
a semester
and these environments are in a list
and the typical student will have five
or six courses that they want to enroll
in
so some pretty simple data access code
we just iterate over each time in the
list and run our insert command
however because of the default auto
commit behavior of the sql server driver
when this code is run there will be an
implicit data comment done each time one
of this statement is executed
what this means is that up on the sql
server sql server has to write an entry
to the transaction log to make sure
there is a record of the dml operation
being performed
so there is a write to the transaction
log incurred each time one of this
statement is executed
what we really intended though with this
code is probably to insert all of the
records at once for the student or none
of the records at all so this work
should be performed inside of a
transaction
this is a pretty common pattern to use a
transaction like this
another example being an e-commerce site
inserting items with an order and we
want all of those inserted to succeed or
none of them so our database is in
consistent state
so to accomplish this we are going to
create a transaction here
then we will pass the transaction to the
constructor of the sql command to attach
it to the command
and finally when all the items are
inserted we commit to the transaction so
this makes much more business sense
but as it turns out it also performs
better because now we are committing
once per student rather than once per
enrollment record
so sql server doesn't have to write to
the transaction log as often
i have some results of when i run this
program before i started recording that
i can show you
and you can see here that using a first
method when we had to the default
autonomic behavior on it took a little
bit more than 30 seconds to insert one
leg 65 000 rows
when i used a transaction
which is also more correct from a
business sense it took a little more
than 23 seconds
so about 7 seconds faster on those same
1 lakh 65 000 rows
now these numbers of course aren't
absolutes and you will likely get
somewhat different results on your
system
but the point is that we want to pay
attention to our commit behavior because
if we are committing after every dml
statement we execute and we really don't
need to
we are imposing more of a load on sql
server and that's going to slow things
down so how often should you commit as
often as your business transaction
dictates
and in some cases that may very well be
after every statement
if not though
just make sure that you are explicitly
using a transaction so you are
controlling the commit behavior and not
using the default auto commit behavior
of the database driver
if you are using an orm most of the time
your orm should be handling this
property for you
however there are some other issues you
want to watch out when you're using an
orm
so we will talk about those in the next
video
you are watching the video module 6
applying common performance practices
part 5 object relational mapper just
generates sql
over the last few years object
relational mappers have become very
popular in the development community
and it's easy to see why orms allow us
to
work at higher level of abstraction and
they also eliminate the need to write a
lot of repetitive data access code to
get data into and out of our database
thereby helping to increase our
productivity as developers
on the downside removing us from having
to work directly with the database gives
us less visibility and less control into
how our data access code is executed
and so one of the side effects of this
is that if you just leave your data
access up to the orm
and don't think about how that data
access is performed you can get very
poor performance
let's see what we mean by this
i have a very simple application here
that is using entity framework
and the intention here is to search all
of the current application who have a
gpa over 3.5 and the math sat score of
over 700 the code here is perfectly
valid and will return the desired
results
the issue is that in this case there is
not an index on any of these columns so
this query will end up performing as
full table scan
which in this case will not result in
very good performance
having an iq variable
we have a fluent interface that is very
flexible and it becomes easy to just
think about attaching the necessary
expression here in code and not to think
what needs to happen when the expression
is converted to sql
and sent to the database
so we just need to keep in mind as we
use our orm ultimately this expression
will turn into sql
and all of the rules we have talked
about in this course
like being properly indexed and having a
query with a selective where clause
still apply if you have any question
about exactly what is happening you can
get the actual sequel that is being
generated by the orm by tracing your
application as we showed in the last
module
or by using some of the client
client-side tracing techniques that are
present in most orms
then once you have the sql you can
generate an execution plan for the
statement and apply all other techniques
we have learned throughout the course to
make sure the statement performs the way
you need to it
then once you have the sql you can
generate an execution plan for the
statement and apply all the other
techniques we have learned throughout
the course
to make sure that statement performs the
way you need it to in the next video we
will look at another issue that
frequently occurs with orm and also
occurs in other scenarios and that is
the n plus 1 query issue
you are watching the video module 6
applying common performance practices
part 6
solving the n plus 1 selects problem
another performance pitfall you want to
be on the lookout for especially when
using an orm is the n plus 1 selects
problem
the problem occurs when you have a
parent object loading its child data
and in loading that child data the data
access layer issues a separate sequence
statement for each child object that
needs to be loaded
let's look at an example of this
we have a piece of code here and what
this code is trying to do is to get the
cumulative gpa for a student
so it needs to get all of the courses
taken by the student
their grades in each course and the
number of credits each course is worth
in order to perform that calculation
so this seems pretty straightforward we
load a student object and then through
the navigation properties on the object
we can get to all of the other data
that we need to do this calculation
what happens though is that initially
our students object doesn't have all of
the data that it needs
so the data for this navigations
property are lazy loaded
i have an extended event session tracing
all of my sql right now
and i am going to actually run this
program so we can see what's happening
and so we see that the program just
prints the name and gpa
but now i am going to switch over to the
trace results so we can see what sql was
run
i have my trace file open here and i
have done a little bit of cleanup to
filter out all of the sp reset
connections messages
that the sql server driver issues when
it retrieves a connection from the
connection pool
so you see right away there are quite a
few statements here that are executing
and if we group these statements
together we actually get a better view
of what's going on
there are some queries in here that are
over headed for entity framework
but we are not worried about those
what we care about are these two
statements that are executed 42 times
each
and if you expanded out the sequel that
in each of those statements
you would see that these two queries
that are grabbing the course offerings
and course records from the database
what is happening is that entity
framework is able to get all of the
courses this student has taken with a
single query from a course enrollment
table
but then in iterates through each of
those course enrollment records and to
get over to the course records where the
number of credits for the class is
stored it first has to get each course
offering record and then each course
record and so one by one it is iterating
through this
lazy loading each of those objects for
however many courses that this student
has taken
and we can see here
this student has taken 42 courses so
that means we have 42 unique courses
offering records we have issued queries
for
and then again 42 unique courses records
that we also had to load
we also had to load some grade records
so we could see what each grade is worth
but there is only two unique values for
those
so
that's just two more statement in this
case
but you see the problem to calculate the
student's gpa
entity framework is having to run 87
individual queries by my count
so that's going to be very chatty and
not very efficient
the issue here is the lazy loading
pattern
which fetches data just as it needed
while this is convenient for many
scenarios
it's not the right pattern for this
scenario because we are having to go
back and forth to the database to get
all of this database piece by piece
what we can do instead is use eager
loading to instruct entity framework to
load all of these data upfront and then
entity framework will create a single
query
that gets all the data we need rather
than issuing all of these little queries
so to do that we just use the include
method up here when we fetch our student
object
so i will put that in now
and this first line is going to tell
entity framework to get all of the
courses offering as well as courses for
the student and the second line will get
all of the grades attached to any of the
course enrollments data so when we get
our student object we will have all the
data we need to do this calculation
so i am going to save this file and
rerun this program so we can get a
second trace of what's happening here
and now we will look at that race we can
see that this time we have only one
statement and in fact if i take this
statement here
and i look at it and i have copied that
in a notepad again so we can do just
that
we see that this one statement is
getting all of the data that we need
so in this case this is going to be much
more efficient because we are not having
to go back and forth to the database
many many times this can happen when you
are lazy loading objects in an orm as we
have just seen
but i have also seen this problem in
traditional data access code
where the code was written in such a way
that it was retrieving all the child
data for an object in an one by one
fashion
the point is when you are loading child
data like this you want to think about
the internals of how that is happening
and make sure that you are not iterating
over some sort of collection and issuing
a sequel statement for each object in
that collection
because that's going to be very chatty
and that's not going to perform very
well
so think about this whenever you are
loading data that's child data of
another object and if needed we don't
hesitate to use one of the various
tracing facilities to make sure that you
are not issuing a whole bunch of
individual sql statements in order to
get the data in the next video let's
wrap up this last module of this course
you are watching the video module 6
applying common performance practices
part 7 module summary
in this module we looked at some
application practices that you want to
make sure and implement for your
application to have the best performance
possible
first we talk about making sure that all
of the sql in your application is
parameterized sql
this not only protects your sql
injection attacks but has a performance
benefit as well
as sql server can reuse the same
execution plan over and over
making your code run faster and saving
resources within sql server
we also talked about stored procedure
and showed that from a performance
standpoint parameters sql and stored
procedures are equivalent
so you can be comfortable choosing
whichever approach best fits for your
situation
then we talk about commit frequency and
how auto commit is turned on in the sql
server driver by default in some cases
it makes sense to commit after each dml
statement
but otherwise using transaction and
committing however often makes logical
business sense
not only in more correct for your
application
it will also perform better as well
finally we talked about orms
orms are a great tool that enhance our
productivity and save us from writing
the same data access code over and over
again
but
this additional level of abstraction
sometimes makes it hard to understand
what is happening inside of sql server
so just remember that ultimately
everything does have to get converted to
a sql statement and then all of the
normal rules about selectivity and
indexing apply
finally if you are loading any child
object especially through lazy loading
be on the lookout for the n plus 1
select problem
basically each child object will load
one by one from the database
and this chattiness has a tendency to
slow down things
so be on a lookout for this and use
eager loading in those situations where
it makes more sense
this brings us to the end of the course
and i hope you have found your time well
spent in learning how sql server works
from a performance standpoint
and what you can do to make sure your
application have optimal performance
we have introduced a wide variety of
concepts and tools that can help you
understand
what sql server is doing
and what you need to do in order to
performance tuning your application
the best course of action now is to get
some hands-on experience with these
tools by looking at an application and
database that you are familiar with
because this is how you really learn
what to look for
and what the data is telling you
thank you very much for your valuable
time
if you have any feedback please feel
free to contact me on twitter at icode
mechanic and you can also send me the
mail on icodemechanic gmail.com
you can also comment in the comment
section down here at youtube
thank you very much again and good luck
for your future